Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome everybody!
Today we are gonna finish Resident Evil 4.
Because I know it's not that long.
Okay, it's like 5 hours I think.
Like around 5 hours.
So it's gonna be a while.
We're gonna be here for a while.
But also, how do I know this?
Because sometimes when I'm like hesitant and be like Did chat tell me the right that I'm like almost done?
I was thinking like, was chat right when I asked them how much I have left of the game?
So sometimes if I don't wanna risk it and I would like look up.
I don't spoil myself.
I just find the exact part where I stop at.
So I'll look up and be like Resident Evil 4 playthrough.
No commentary.
And then I try and find the area where I stop.
And I can't believe I got gaslit.
I got gaslit so fucking hard in that Ashley level.
Remember that level where you guys were like Oh my god Doki, how dare you skip that part because somebody told you the answer for the clock.
That was like one minute.
One minute.
Because the piece of paper where I find the time of like how much I had to like of the time of the clock was literally right next to me.
It was like one minute that I missed.
And then people in that chat were like wow Doki how fucking could you eliminating that content from us.
How could you Doki?
I can't believe it.
Wow.
It was one minute of content.
I can't believe all of you yelled at me for one minute of content.
I thought I missed out on something very important.
Like I was like oh my god.
I missed out on something very important.
Did I actually skip like 30 minutes of the Ashley level?
It was one minute.
It was fucking one minute.
The paper was right next to me.
Oh my god.
We missed one minute of Doki being skipped.
How could you Doki?
How could you do this to us?
It was one fucking minute.
I was like wow let me see how much I actually missed out on by doing the clock like right away instead of trying to find the clue.
I can't fucking believe you guys.
She's on to us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
D-Dragon finish it Doki.
I've never seen the island.
I don't wait.
Good luck on today's run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It would have been a viral clip Doki.
You don't understand.
Also, did you guys hear about the ALGS stuff?
I was watching it live on Nice Wig stream.
Because I was curious.
And then I...
And I was like... and then like I tabbed out and was like looking at my Twitter.
And then people were like talking about it.
So for those who don't follow Apex Legends.
E-sports scene.
Two pro players got hacked live during the tournament.
And this is not just like a regular... it was like basically the finals to LAN.
So like whoever does really well in the finals for Apex goes to LAN.
So like this was like real shit.
So it was the... okay I'm sorry.
I know it's so fucked up.
But it was so funny.
Because like...
So the two players were JenBurden and ImperialHal.
And it was so funny because when it happened to JenBurden.
He was like I'm getting hacked.
I'm getting hacked.
And then he left the game instantly.
And then...
And then when it happened to Hal.
Hal was like oh my god.
I'm getting hacked.
But what if I just stop shooting?
Because he's like but what if I just don't shoot guys?
What if I just don't shoot?
I'm cheating.
And then...
And then they were like...
And then he proceeds to kill people with aimbot.
It was so fucking funny.
He's like...
He just started...
Proceeds to keep playing.
And also continues to kill people with aimbot.
And then they were like...
And then like other pro players were like why the fuck did you not leave?
And then Hal was like...
I don't know.
He was like...
No.
That 1v1 I had was my aim assist.
Like I know I did that.
And then people were like...
People were like...
It's so fucked up when you can't tell if it's aim assist or if it was aimbot.
Like no one knows.
Because no one knows if he used aimbot or if it was aim assist.
Because we can't tell.
It was...
We can't tell.
They were like...
It was like 1v1.
And they were like up close.
So no one knows which one it was.
So like people can't tell if it was off or not.
And...
So that happened during the Apex tournament.
And the scary thing is that no one knows how this person did it.
It's apparently like a security breach.
But the thing is...
I think like what people...
Like...
Okay.
So like this hacker...
A lot of like the normies are like really scared.
They're like...
Oh!
Don't turn on...
Don't play Apex right now.
Don't do it.
Don't play Apex.
Uninstall Apex.
Don't even touch it.
Because there's a security breach.
But like the thing is...
Only this hacker has that...
Has that power.
This is only like...
It's a very well known...
This hacker has been around in the Apex community for a while.
He always does these crazy hacks.
On like pro players.
But this is like the first time...
He is...
He has like...
He has like done this in the tournament.
Because he's hacked HAL.
And he has...
He has hacked HAL.
And he has hacked Mandate before in the past.
This is the same hacker.
So like...
People don't know yet.
So like a lot of people are scared.
Because they're like...
Oh what if it's my turn next?
Yeah.
He's just there.
He's doing it for publicity basically.
Like he's just some kid that's doing this for publicity.
Some very fucking smart kid.
I don't know.
So I feel like right now...
I know it's like if you want to be safe, don't touch Apex.
But most likely...
Like since he's like the only kid that has like this power.
Like the people out there that are not like public figures.
They're okay.
Like they're okay.
Like the non-public figures are okay right now.
Because...
Because he's just targeting.
He's done this before.
He's breached the Apex like security.
My god.
Multiple times before.
But this has been like the biggest publicity stunt he has ever done.
You know when like...
Okay so those who have seen the clip of like the Jen Burnham clip.
When he like brought up a...
When he brought up the aimbot.
Because like he brings up the aimbot.
If you look so closely.
If you look closely at the aimbot like app that he had open.
It's...
It's a fucking meme.
It's not even a real like aimbot app.
Like the stuff in that...
In the dialogue.
If there's a screenshot.
Yeah there's a screenshot of it.
And it's not even the real...
It's not even like an actual app.
This kid made a fucking PNG.
Like he made like a fucking...
He made his own app.
He made his own fucking app.
Like a fake client.
Just to troll people on stream.
Like...
Oh my god.
You know this is a 15 year old kid.
You fucking know.
This is a 15 year old kid who did that.
A very smart 15 year old kid though.
A very smart one.
But yeah.
It's actually...
It's actually crazy.
Uh...
It's actually insane that this happened.
At best if you really do want to be safe.
I guess just don't play Apex at the moment.
If you're actually like super paranoid.
But I think like...
For it...
Like...
There's no...
Like I feel like they're just...
He's just targeting like public figures at the moment.
To make a statement regarding the security of EA servers.
Because like...
He's done this before.
And the thing is...
He's been the only hacker that's been doing this.
Other than Toofy.
Before him...
It was Toofy.
And then Toofy got sued to oblivion.
And now...
That's why he's gone.
The reason why Toofy's not here anymore.
Is because he actually got sued.
So like...
Now he's gone.
So now it's this fucking 15 year old kid that's doing all of this.
And he's like...
He's like...
He's like the successor of Toofy.
So...
So that's...
And they always do it for publicity.
Like...
Like the thing is...
I'm not worried.
Because like...
I'm not worried or scared.
These people only do it for publicity.
In a way.
Like if he...
They really wanna like fuck people over.
They would not have like told people that they were hacking.
They would just actually do it for publicity.
Just like...
Just like not even tell anybody that like...
Like...
Like he...
They would throw Jen Burden under the bus.
And make people believe that he was actually hacking.
But he did all of this for publicity.
So that's why I'm not like...
I'm not like worried about it.
Or anything.
And like...
People are still like...
You know...
Like...
If the pros are still playing Apex.
Then they know some...
I know some stuff too.
Then they...
Then...
Then they know something we don't.
Because if the pros are still playing Apex rank.
And like they're still playing Apex.
Then they know something that we don't.
Or...
So...
So that's why I like...
I'm not like really worried.
Butch Top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
15 year old versus indie developer EA.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also like...
Yeah.
So there's like...
We have a challenger circuit.
I don't know what's gonna be...
Go on.
With that for now.
I don't know what's happening with that.
So like...
It might be delayed.
I don't know.
Because like right now...
All tournaments are at...
Like the...
The pro league is...
Postponed at the moment.
So it might...
Affect...
Challenger circuit.
So...
We don't know.
I'm waiting for like...
An announcement about what's going on and stuff.
So at the moment, I'm just... we're just waiting.
It could be delayed, the challenger circuit at that point.
It could be... it could be delayed.
Anyway, what else?
Oh yes!
And also Razer sent me some stuff!
I actually received it recently.
I'm so happy!
I finally have a full keyboard!
When they asked me, they were like, oh hey Doki, do you want a 60%?
Because you know, I'm known to use 60% keyboards.
Or like 65% keyboards.
And I was like, no I would like a full keyboard.
Because they were like, what size keyboard do you want?
And I was like, do you want 60% or a full?
I was like, a full keyboard.
Because I have zero full keyboards by the way.
All my keyboards are like cut in some way.
They're like... they're like minimal.
Not minimal, what's the word?
They're like... they cut out some keys that I don't normally use.
Because you know, for efficiency sake and for like space wise.
So I was like, no I would like a full keyboard.
I would like a full keyboard for once in my life.
So I finally... so yeah, huge shout out to Razer.
They reached out to me and was like, we really want to send you some gaming gear.
And I was like, me?
For free?
So yeah, I got some...
Free gaming gear.
I'm so...
This is... it's actually crazy.
Like Skypad and Razer and like...
Many more... he can't say anything.
It's actually crazy.
I've never had this opportunity before.
So I was like, really really surprised.
Because it's like, you know, I thought that like, you know...
I don't know, I just thought I was like a nobody.
Like no one really wanted me to, you know, represent their brand or anything.
Because I never had that opportunity before.
So I was like, really really surprised.
And why would I ever say no to free stuff?
You know?
Why would I ever say no to free stuff?
It's free!
Like...
So yeah, it's actually crazy.
There's like so many things that's gonna happen in the future.
Like so many amazing opportunities.
I can't really... I can't say anything about it.
Because like, you know, NDA reasons.
And like when it happens, it happens.
When it's announced, it's announced.
But like, a lot of things definitely to look forward to.
By the way guys, just like, you know, this is just the beginning.
So yeah, anyway.
Today we are gonna fucking play Resident Evil 4.
And I hope to God we can finish this game today.
I hope... I will fucking finish this game today.
Oh my God, there is like so much...
It might be like fucking...
Six more chapters.
But we can do this, I believe.
You guys might be like, but Doki, it's like 3 AM, Doki.
It's time.
Tell your... phone in your boss.
And be like, I can't...
Use your sick days.
You have one... I know you have at least one sick day.
But that's a joke.
Please don't like ditch work for me.
Predictable.
Please don't ditch work for me guys.
I...
Because working grants you money.
And by having money, you can pay for internet bills.
And by paying internet bills, you can watch me.
And then by watching me, you support me.
And then to support me, you have to go to work.
And then... yeah, it's a circle.
It's a circle.
Please don't skip work.
Ada?
Assuming you haven't.
I've got a tip for you.
Hello Ada.
Seems like something big is about to go down in the throne room.
The throne room?
Where the fuck is the throne...
Oh my god, I'm so happy I don't have...
Ada!
I don't have to deal with Ashley anymore.
I'm so fucking happy.
No more Ashley.
Okay, let's see.
What do I have?
Okay, I still have a lot of bullets.
That's good.
Hello!
Hello sir.
I lost Ashley.
Thank fucking god.
Haha.
Alright, let's see.
Do I save up for the upgrade ticket?
Should I save up for the upgrade ticket or should I buy...
No, I should save up.
I should actually save up though.
Let's see.
Striker...
38,000.
How much money?
I do not have a lot of money.
Okay, is the striker good?
Is it worth it?
Is it worth it or nah?
Is it worth it or nah, guys?
This is very important.
Let's see.
1, 2, 3...
No?
Okay, no.
Okay, I won't use the striker then.
Alright, here we go.
Haha.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watching from work right now so I can afford super chats.
You know what's an even bigger brain play?
Work so hard that you get promoted.
So...
Hahaha.
Work so hard that you can get promoted.
And then by being promoted, you can watch me more.
And support me more.
That's a big brain play, guys.
Cal, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Watch Doki while working.
Infinite Doki glitch.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alright, where do I have to go?
Okay, I have to go through...
Let's see.
Is there any like missions I need to do?
Can you go...
Oh, I need to go through that room.
Alright.
Is it this room, right?
This is the room I opened.
Yeah, this is my room I opened.
What's this?
Oh, the emerald.
Nice.
Free shit.
I love free shit.
Uh...
Where the fuck is this room?
Wait, where do I have to go?
Okay, the throne.
Oh, I have to go there for the throne room.
Which means...
I just have to go there.
I'm a secret brave soul willing to dispose of that monstrosity of a knight.
But B Warren is much stronger than the others.
He cut down our best with a single strike.
It's okay.
I have a flashbang.
Do I have a flashbang?
I do not have a flashbang.
Amelia, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
If I don't go to work, then I can't send you Akasupas though.
So what is the real solution here?
You go to work.
I don't know what else I'm supposed to tell you.
Oh, I do have a flashbang.
You go to work.
Like, what do you want me to say?
Oh, no.
Not the dark.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
Is this the...
Is this the library?
Is this the fucking...
Am I heading to the library?
No, this is the library.
Okay.
This is the...
What is this?
Is this the...
Oh, this is the knight.
Okay, now it's dark.
It's okay.
I have a gun.
I'm not as scared.
I'm not as scared, guys.
I have a gun.
I'm not as scared.
I have gun.
Wait, how do I get this?
There's, like...
Is this above me?
Okay, this is the second floor.
Okay.
I have gun.
I'm not as scared.
Where are you?
I know you're here.
Oh, this is it.
This is the Ashley room.
Okay, gun is always the answer.
Alright.
Where are you?
I have gun, you can't fuck with me this time!
I know you're here!
I know you're here because I screamed when I was in here!
That's why I know!
Alright, actually... okay, this is where the knight is.
Alright.
I have an overdue book.
I would go to the library to just rent out VeggieTales.
That was like the only time I ever go to the library.
I only ever went to the library to rent the Arthur PC games and the VeggieTales potatoes.
Oh, the third rat!
Where's the third rat?
Guys, where's the third rat?
I forgot about the rat.
Is it above here?
VeggieTales, VeggieTales, VeggieTales.
Broccoli, celery, ba-ba-dum.
I always forget that VeggieTales was like super fucking religious.
I just thought they were funny veggies.
They were just funny veggies to me.
Back in the hall.
Oh, it's in the animal heads.
You're just silly little vegetables.
Where the fuck?
Oh, there you are.
Stop running.
Stop running!
Oh my god!
Stop!
There you go.
I did it.
The rat exterminator is here.
Yeah, like, did you guys know they fired the creat- They fired the creators of VeggieTales.
Not very Christian of them to do.
But that's what they did.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not very- Show up on like Christian values and then they fired the creators.
Like, what the fuck?
Don't- Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I should do listen to Doki while working.
Sadly, I can't always pay full attention to you.
But I tried.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's alright.
As long as like you're still supporting me in your own way.
Oh, that has to be.
That has to be the merciless knight.
He seems pretty fucking big.
Doki recognizes no god.
Only Larry.
Thank you for the super chat, Matty.
Thank you.
Alright.
Big boy.
Hello, big boy.
That is our big boy.
Wait, they can run now?
What the fuck?
It's okay.
It's okay!
Yike!
Woooo!
It's okay!
Kick!
And then run!
And then I...
Oh, how am I missing?
How am I missing?
Okay.
This is like fucked up a little bit because it's so fucking dark!
What the fuck is so fa- This is a little bit harder.
I just realized how dark this is.
Oh god.
It's okay.
I need to get all of them out of the little hidey hole.
Fuck!
It's okay.
Kick!
Come on!
Get out of your little hidey hole!
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, I didn't see him!
I didn't see him!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Please.
Please, it's so dark.
Please, it's so fucking dark.
I cannot see!
Ah!
Shit!
It's okay!
Alright, okay, okay, I'm gonna use the shotgun.
Everything...
Everything shows up in the shotgun!
But let me kill you first.
Alright.
Oh god.
All the pellets!
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
I'm just hoping all the pellets come out.
There we go.
That's fine!
Flashbang!
Boom.
No, no, no, no, that's not the flashbang!
You should be dead now.
There we go.
Easy.
So fucking easy.
Alright!
There you go.
We're fine.
I don't think all of these guys are gonna try and kill me, so we'll be fine.
And this is what the fish is for.
Fish!
Fish time!
Do I need to go here?
Do I need to?
I don't, right?
Pretty sure I don't.
I think I killed everything here.
I grabbed the loot there before.
Thank you for the gift of the ship!
Thank you!
No?
I'm pretty sure I got the...
Oh, I can?
Alright.
That was just for bonus mission.
Alright, nice.
We're good.
We're good to go.
We got loot for the merchant.
There you go.
That's fine.
There is a gun in the library?
Where the fuck is that gun?
Yeah, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you for the love of everything to made a press alt on that inventory.
No.
I hope this pisses you off even more.
I don't need AI to help me sort my inventory.
I don't need it.
I have...
I have my own skill.
Okay.
I want to go back to grab some stuff from the merchant.
I'm a gamer!
I'm not gonna let AI sort my guns!
Alright, this way.
I'm gonna go sell my stuff.
This is my order.
This is the Doki order.
It's art.
You won't understand.
Yay!
Wait, I got two.
Oh yeah, I got the rats too!
Wait, can I have enough?
Fuck!
I'm like one short.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
I might as well like...
do this too.
Uhhhh...
Yeah, two of the same color.
I might as well.
Okay.
Uhhhh... yes!
And then... yes!
Alright, and this one needs one, two, three.
I don't think I'm gonna get three of a kind.
Oh, I wasn't even gonna have three of a kind.
Anyway.
Alright, we're gonna sell you.
Yay!
Time to save.
Save game.
Alright.
We need to...
We need to go back to the library anyway.
Sorry, extra loot.
Loot time.
Gonna reload my shotgun.
Alright!
It's time to go in and kill some more knights.
Open up!
I went the wrong way.
Okay.
Alright.
Time to go back this way.
And grab some more loot.
Alright.
We gotta grab that rifle.
Is that rifle even good or is it just a selling rifle?
Is that rifle just like money rifle?
It's just for money, right?
Oh god, I hate this.
I hate that it's still so dark.
Someone turn on the fucking lights.
I know you're here.
Like, I know you exist.
Come on.
Walk over here, please.
Just walk over here.
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
Thank you for walking over.
I really appreciate that.
You guys just walk over, please.
Thank you.
Where's the other one?
Wait, are they not gonna walk over?
Are they stuck?
No, this guy's walking over.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that, sir.
You get closer, you're way too far from me.
There we go.
Boom!
Alright.
Can you get closer?
It's convenient!
I don't wanna waste my energy!
Walk closer.
Okay, I know you're to my right.
There you are.
You get a little closer.
Oh my god, the fucking statue.
Okay, I think I hit him, right?
Okay, I don't know.
Guys!
You get a little closer.
Nice, thank you.
Thank you.
It's nice because I don't have to waste my energy.
You get a little bit closer.
Thank you.
Efficiency!
I love efficiency.
Alright, where is that fucking chest?
How many crows has Doki killed?
Not as much as I would like, even though they owe me so much money.
Wait, I don't even have the key.
No!
I forgot to...
Ashley, you were supposed to unlock this!
Why couldn't you drop the key when you were getting kidnapped?
Ashley, how could you?
Ashley didn't drop the keys when she was getting kidnapped.
So inefficient, Ashley.
So fucking inefficient.
Okay, this has to be the fucking...
Okay, this has to be the...
Uh...
This has to be the...
What is it?
The...
Okay, I think this is it.
No.
The rifle.
Uh...
Is this how you do it?
Nope.
Nope, not this way.
Okay, I think this is it.
Is it this one?
Nope.
Uh...
Oh, it's a square!
No...
Is it like this?
I keep putting...
Oh, here!
I did it.
I'm so smart.
Yay!
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
God damn it.
Now I actually have it to inventory manage.
I can't find it.
I can't believe it.
I let them win.
I hope you're happy, guys.
Now I actually have to inventory manage.
Uh...
There, are you happy now?
You can tell I play Tetris.
That is the Tetris brain going on.
Alright, now I can sell this.
Finally.
Anything for Gun.
I know what game to start for next week.
Because we do have a lot of Steam games.
Oh my God!
I know what game I want to start next week after we finish Resident Evil 4.
I want to finally play Dead Rise.
I know!
It's like, Doki, you bought so many new games on your Steam sale.
Guys!
But what about Dead Rise?
I don't understand.
What these guys are thinking.
I see...
Guys, just think about that!
Which gun did I just brought?
Guys wait.
Which gun did I...
Okay, is this.
Is this a good gun?
Or not?
Ugly, thank you for the superchat.
How did you manage to escape a dungeon?
Is this a.
Is this a good gun or not?
Don't sell it.
Why?
Why though?
Is it actually good?
I don't know.
Guys, I have so many guns!
Guys!
I have so many guns, guys!
Little to no damage?
Okay, I'm selling it.
Alright, I'll sell the rifle.
It's too late.
I'm selling it.
Say 07.
It's time to 07 this.
Goodbye!
Alright, let's see.
I'll save my game.
I'm gonna save here just in case.
Just in case I did make a mistake.
Just in case.
Alright, let's see.
Now we can progress the level!
Alright.
Oh yeah.
I just want to be a journalist.
I've covered wars, you know.
Uh... Alright.
Dead Rising is actually... What the are you?!
What?!
Chink!
Oh my god!
There's bugs?!
I just realized I never got this far.
I've never got this far!
Alright.
This is locked.
Where do I go?
How do I get there?
Do I jump down?
Oh, there.
There.
I can't believe it.
Mothmen.
Oh god.
Jesus Christ.
I can't even loot them.
That's the worst part!
I can't even loot these fuckers!
Oh, God, please tell me there's ammo here.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
At least there's ammo for me here.
Oh, I need that.
I need that so badly.
I was running out of handgun ammo too.
Oh, thank God I'm on normal!
Thank fucking God.
I appreciate the simple things.
Being on normal difficulty so I have loot.
Thank fucking God.
The true horror.
Oh, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you to keep planning the cover wars, you know.
That's right.
It's time to be a journalist.
So I'm excused to play on journalism.
Journalist mode.
Black liquid into the body.
Or at the precipice of success.
The womb is the key.
A pure soul proves to be a highly malleable and adaptive subject.
He's talking about me!
I'm so pure.
January.
Six years since my awakening.
I've named the sacred larvae carried in the womb of the chosen after my own.
They shall carry the prestige of my family name.
Oh, the U2!
Are they gonna be playing in the...
What was it?
In the globe.
Not Bono!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Pure evil you mean.
Oh, he's talking about the red guys!
Those are the red rope guys!
Because they were like buggy.
Next form of evolution.
Return to bug.
Honestly, I feel like bugs are like pretty...
Pretty like...
What is it?
What's the word?
They're pretty like hardcore.
In the evolution.
Evolution line.
Because they like...
There's like...
You know, like some bugs they can't fucking die.
Because they have like hard exoskeletons.
And then they like...
Breed like crazy.
So they can like produce like thousands and millions of insects at once.
Like the queen can just lay a thousand fucking insects and stuff.
And it's like what?
And then like their ta...
Okay, they're not...
They're like strong too.
Like ants, they can like hold up like...
Times ten their fucking...
Body weight and stuff.
And they're pretty resilient.
Yeah.
So like in a way, they are sort of like better than humans.
If they were like human size, I would be very fucking scared about a human-sized insect.
Like...
That's the only thing there's...
That...
That's the only thing that's stopping them.
They're just too fucking tiny.
If they were bigger...
If they were bigger, then they would be like scary.
They would actually be like really fucking scary.
They're...
We're just lucky that they're so fucking tiny.
Honestly.
They will collapse?
You don't know that.
They're fucking buff as hell.
Wait, where did...
No!
He dropped into the fucking hole!
Stupid bug.
Wait, I hear them.
Come on.
Oh my god, the reload.
Okay, stab.
There's always an end.
That's why I'm not afraid.
Oh, fuck!
Holy shit!
Give me a sec!
I didn't...
I didn't think there'd be more!
I thought there'd be an end!
Okay.
Oh shit!
You fucking stupid bug!
I'm gonna stab you.
Stab.
Aim for the eyes?
Which one?
I don't know if you guys know this, but bugs have a lot of eyes.
Oh, thank god.
There's a lot of handgun ammo.
Thank fucking god.
Okay.
Let's see.
There is a lot of gear here.
I have to go this way.
All of them?
That's one.
One too many.
That's one too many.
Okay, that's fucking right.
You can't fucking fool me.
I know a bug when I see one.
How the fuck do I get there?
Okay, not that.
Not you!
Except for you.
Just in case.
Up.
Okay.
I know there's one more somewhere.
Aim for the lower left.
Second.
From the third.
From the last row.
I'm gonna chat!
This is fucked up.
What the fuck?
I'm just gonna stab you.
I'm gonna stab.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna stab you.
What are you gonna do?
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Get stabbed!
Everyone gets one.
Okay.
I'm looking this time.
Okay, I'm making sure...
I'm making sure I'm safe.
Alright, I got a hand grenade.
I know there's like- I'm missing a loot here somewhere.
Where the fuck is it?
Welcome to London again.
Oh, there it is.
Right in front of me.
Alright, I need a heal.
I'm so fucked up.
I'm gonna eat the fish.
Wait, actually- Oh, wait, I am fucked up.
Okay.
I'm gonna eat the fish.
I was pretty fucked up.
Let's see, which way do I go?
What is that over here?
There's treasure over here.
I'm gonna go this way for the treasure.
Always for the loot.
What the fuck is crawling?
Come on, that's right.
That's fucking right, you can't fool me.
That's fucking right.
Stab you.
Stab!
Woo!
There you go.
Can't fool me this time.
Stab!
Nice.
Free loot.
Oh!
Woo!
No!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Alright, I was a little worried.
Wait.
I'm gonna stab the people behind me.
I hear you.
I fucking knew it.
Fucking knew it.
I knew you were there.
Let me stab you.
I'm gonna stab you too.
I'm gonna stab you.
That's fucking right.
No!
Wait!
Wait, that broke my knife?
Oh, I broke my knife.
Guys.
I think I stabbed a little bit too much, guys.
Just a little bit too much.
It's okay.
I have my kitchen knife though.
I still have my kitchen knife.
It's okay.
I got the kitchen knife.
What can they do about it?
Alright, let's grab this.
And then... chest time.
Oh, nice.
Money.
I love money.
How do I get over there?
Please.
I just wanna loot.
I forgot to upgrade my knife.
Please.
Okay, we need a...
Let me open this.
Open?
Open!
Shortcut!
Yay!
Is this a shortcut?
I'm gonna go back.
We need to fix my knife.
How else am I gonna be stabbing some bugs?
Alright, this way.
This way.
Merchant!
I need you to fix my knife.
I stabbed one too many bugs.
I love shortcuts.
Tune up.
Repair.
Good luck to you, sir.
Uhhh...
Oh my god.
I have no armor.
Okay.
Uh...
I might as well upgrade the power and the durability here.
I feel like...
I feel like I'm gonna be using this a lot.
I stabbed one too many bugs.
Okay.
It's okay.
Equip.
Yeah.
That's right.
This has to be... Oh!
I go the right way.
This way.
Alright.
Here we go.
Back.
Oh shit!
Forgot to upgrade!
Oh my god!
The only reason I had to come back!
I forgot to upgrade.
Oh, I almost forgot.
Alright.
Trade.
Nice.
Finally!
How do I upgrade this?
A hundred thousand dollars?!
Alright.
How much money do I have?
Oh!
Why did I upgrade the knife?!
Why did you guys stop me?!
Why did you not stop me?!
Okay.
We're gonna... Well, we have like so many of these.
Three of a kind.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh!
It's the money or the ticket?
Oh, okay.
That's it.
That's good.
I can just use the ticket!
Okay.
Two and up.
I can just use the ticket!
Oh!
I almost did the knife.
That would've been so embarrassing.
That would've been so fucking awkward.
Yay!
Alright.
Let me sell the hornet and the butterfly lamp.
And then we should be good.
Imagine though...
And then it turns into a knife only run.
But the amount of money I spent on that fucking knife...
It's gonna turn into a knife only run.
Alright.
Back in we go.
Neil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bugs can't be human sized because the oxygen density in the air is too low to support them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're right.
This is why we have global...
To prevent the size of the bugs from growing bigger.
It's a risk.
Either fuck the environment or...
Yeah.
The environment is fucked.
But...
The bugs are smaller now.
Guys, think about it.
Just think about it, chat.
Yeah.
We might have fucked...
Like we might have fucked over the world.
But now we don't have to deal with like giant sized bugs.
It's worth it.
Don't keep... please.
The priorities.
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
Where are the bugs?
I don't like this.
This seems too bug free.
I don't like how...
Wait.
No.
This is where I came from.
Sorry.
I went the wrong way.
I...
Wait.
Doki goes the wrong way again.
Yay!
It's this way.
This should be the right way, right?
It might be going the same way again.
Or was that the right way?
I can't.
I'm just way too...
Oh no.
No.
I've never been here.
Because there's a box.
I know I haven't been here because there's a box there.
I don't like how...
I don't like how bug free this area is though.
There we go.
I fucking knew it.
Give me a sec.
Melee!
That's fucking right.
Stab!
Nice.
Alright.
Where's the other bug?
I saw you.
I know you exist.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Where the fuck are you?
Where are you?
Closer.
Oh fuck!
But not that close!
Not that close!
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Fuck you.
There we go.
I know I should like actually shoot them because that was a waste of my health.
But like it was worth it.
Look.
I spent a lot of money upgrading this knife.
Chat.
A lot of money was spent on this knife.
I'm gonna use that knife.
Okay.
We can put this together.
We just need yellow herbs.
Why is yellow herb so fucking hard to find?
I don't understand.
It's like yellow.
Like...
That should already be easy.
It's literally yellow.
You're the 1% who upgrades dude.
No!
I'm pretty sure there's more people that upgrades their knives.
Oh that's a big one.
That took two shots to kill.
There's no way.
I can't be.
There has to be speedrunners.
Speedrunners can't be the 1%.
There's no way.
There's an entire fucking charity event dedicated to them.
It's like at least 2%.
Guys.
At least 2%.
Yay.
AHHH!
SHIT!
HOLY SHIT.
He just slapped me!
Okay.
We're definitely.
We're definitely gonna need a heal now.
I'm gonna use the sprint.
Alright.
Here we go.
Is this the door I opened?
No.
Where the fuck did I open?
Which gate?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
This is the gate I open.
This is... no, this is...
Okay.
There's a ladder?
Oh, it's this way.
Alright.
No, we're not lost, guys.
We're never lost.
We're not lost, guys.
I just need to go up a ladder.
Okay, that's a bug.
I can tell.
I can fucking tell that's a bug.
Alright.
Gate time!
Alright, that should be both gates.
Trust the process.
You just have to keep trusting.
Oh, drop down.
Drop down!
Alright, now...
Nice.
More handgun ammo.
That's really good that they dropped this.
It's like modern bug spray.
I'm not shooting the fucking thing again.
Yeah, I just have a gun.
I'm a better version of a knight.
Wait, was that it?
Bro, this could have been a text message.
Bro, you could have texted me this.
Don't you hate it when people just call you to give you like one sentence of a message?
Bro, you're wasting my data.
Alright.
What do you mean this part?
Why are you giving me so much ammo?
Hmm.
This could have been an email.
Honestly, true.
I hate getting into like calls for meetings.
I'm just like, can't you just text me this?
Like...
Fucking hate it.
Why is there a yellow over there?
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
That's one of them.
That's so true though.
Like, just fucking text me.
You do not need me there.
Oh my god, where the fuck is the other one?
Where the fuck is the other one?
Where is that?
That's just yellow ping.
Where is it?
You're gonna hate this?
Why do I hate this?
Oh, it's over here.
No, you know what?
I actually have unlimited data.
But I should like use that excuse.
I can be like, I'm sorry.
I have limited data.
I'm trying to save money.
I say as I'm...
That's actually such a good excuse.
Holy shit.
Wait.
If I wanna get out of like, calls and stuff.
Okay, here we go.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Do I have...
Will I get like, ganked?
No, right?
Oh, nice crit.
Wait, is that...
No.
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys, I sort of fucked up.
But I can kill them.
Guys.
Trust.
I can totally kill them.
Just gotta run.
I just gotta run.
It's fine.
I can totally kill these people.
Fuck!
Oh shit!
I didn't realize there were more of them!
Friendly fire!
Oh shit!
This is worth it.
This is so worth it.
Friendly fire!
Okay.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
This is so fucking fine.
Do not worry.
This is so fine!
I told you!
Friendly fire!
Okay.
Nice.
One.
Woo!
Come on, turn around.
Okay.
Turn around.
I'm just gonna kill this lady first.
This lady is annoying.
Woo!
Friendly fire!
Please!
There are so many instances of friendly fire!
How are you still people alive there?
Woo!
Kill each other.
Please.
Yes!
Oh shit!
No!
Not the guy!
Oh shit!
Friendly fire!
Oh my god.
Yes.
Kill all of your friends.
Woo!
How?
What did you do?
Shoot the bomb!
What?
What the fuck?
Oh how the fuck did I like dodge that?
Yes!
Oh thank god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There you go.
I'm just gonna kill him because I really can't be bothered to deal with this guy.
Woo!
Shit!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
It's just him.
It's just me and him.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh there he is.
Yes!
Is he dead?
He's dead!
I'm dead!
You did it!
I told you.
By the power of friendly fire.
I told you!
I knew it.
I knew friendly fire was on my side.
I fucking knew it.
Nice.
The Doki style.
The Doki style always works.
It might not be the traditional style, but it always works.
It has a 100% success rate.
Alright, we need to make more shotgun ammo.
Let me see.
Craft shotgun shells.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I got reloaded.
Wait, there's a bell?
I still don't know where the bell is.
All I know is to run.
That's all I need to know.
I don't need to know where the bell is.
I just need them to kill each other.
Alright, here we go.
Gunpowder.
Oh, there's the bell!
We...
We did it!
Found the bell!
We
did it!
Okay.
Wow, guys.
We fucking did it.
We found the bell.
Alright, let's see.
There is... mine's over here.
There you go.
Nice.
Or this.
Oh.
And then... boop!
Yay!
The roundhouse kicker.
It's the thons.
Oddball, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Doki style.
30% of the time.
It works every time.
Is that Ashley?
What's she yelling about?
What are you yelling about, Ashley?
Oh, shit.
Whose blood is that?
Oh,
shit.
Who the fuck is that?
Oh, my God.
Is this the Purif...
Global warming!
You failed me!
Oh.
You're not going to resist.
I did it.
Six lives.
Exactly.
All the worse.
Please.
Please stop.
Oh, my God.
Are they like speed running?
Fast traveling?
It's like gacha upgrades.
You know?
They paid a thousand dollars to make sure she level up faster.
They can't wait the two hours.
Ah.
Like, you want to use this diamond to make her level 12.
Oh, shit.
I'll pay you next time.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Jake, I think I caught you in a fight.
This is great.
He is like Lian!
I'm not sure if I can get the chain down there.
Why the fuck do they have a chain there?
No, no, no!
Why is it so dark?
Why can't I just have lights?
Why can't they just light up the pit?
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
Oh my god, I hate this.
AHHHH!
Fuck, okay.
Why can't they install lighting in here?
Who's gonna clean this up?
Why is the cave pit not lit up?
I KNOW!
It doesn't make sense!
I don't understand.
Pro Leon.
Time and place, man.
Who are you telling this to?
Who?
It's just you and me and you don't even know I exist.
Okay.
There might be stuff here, right?
Does he have things?
No?
Why is there like a random indent here?
Oh my god!
What a fucking dork.
This is the one Chris wants to continue to bloodline.
Woah!
What the fuck was that?
What's that?
The fuck was that?
I think I hate most is just the flashlight.
It's just so fucking...
It's still so dark.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How could this happen to me?
I made my mistakes.
Ba da da da da.
I don't like this at all.
Okay.
I hate this.
I hate this room.
I hate this pit.
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Jesus!
Oh my god.
That's the worst part.
It was so fast.
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I shoot that?
It's just a little guy.
Bro, it was so fucking fast.
I feel like...
Do they have a queen?
Those bugs?
Am I supposed to kill the queen bug?
Oh no.
Why?
I see you.
Oh no.
I literally see you.
Get out!
Jump in.
God fucking...
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
I know you're here.
Where are you?
I literally saw you swim.
Oh my god.
I don't see it anywhere.
What have I...
I'm making some noise.
Oh!
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
God fucking...
What's my HP?
God fucking damn it.
Okay, I'm gonna use...
I'll use my spray if I get hit one more time.
Alright.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
God.
What is this?
What is this pathway?
Hooray!
Okay.
Off we go.
Pay attention to the water.
This fucking sucks.
God damn it.
Get over here.
Okay, one bug down.
Oh my god.
Not to look down?
Gamers don't look down!
What is this bullshit?
That was so fast!
Okay.
One down.
God damn it.
Alright.
Oh!
Can't believe it's trying to train me to look down.
What is this?
This is not made for gamers.
Not my game.
Not my Resident Evil!
Where do I go?
I wonder what's over there.
No, I'm not gonna risk it.
I don't even think the loot's worth...
Wait, can I just steal it from here?
Wait, okay.
Come on.
Come on, just rivet to me through...
Oh my god, I still actually have to go there.
I actually...
I actually have to...
There's some... I don't wanna eat this.
I don't wanna eat like fucking...
coarse fish, guys.
They...
All the fishes here are like marinated with bug...
bug juice and corpses.
Why the fuck would I ever eat any of the bugs...
any of the fishes here?
It's like they could have parasites!
Okay, anyway, let's kill...
eat this fish.
Anyway.
Let's eat that one though.
That one's okay.
That fish is okay.
Could be yummy.
That fish might have some parasites.
But that's okay.
Another one dead.
How long has it been since I was thrown down here?
The meager scraps of food provided in the beginning are gone.
And they don't give us more.
The pains of hunger and thirst are unbearable.
Most have resorted to drinking the black water.
The first time I was here, I was like, Oh, you have to turn with me.
was Herminio.
He was so weak he couldn't even walk.
But then suddenly, he became MAD.
By the time his rampage ended, two were dead.
I think we shouldn't drink that dark liquid.
Dear Abelardo has also passed, though he fought until the very end.
The only thing I can do now is honor the bodies The god is God.
Oh hey, a crab.
How do I get that though?
Oh, can I just like... destroy it?
Kick!
God, my thighs.
God is dead.
Oh, finally some yellow herbs.
Put that here.
Alright, up we go.
Whoa!
What's going on?
Is it because I'm a bug now?
Is it because I'm half bug and I'm getting drowned?
I don't... oh my god, why?
Why is... I'm getting my shotgun.
Oh, no.
Oh, flashing lights?
Let me grab this gun.
Just in case, you know.
The flashing lights is not very reassuring.
Alright.
Oh, loot.
Loot!
Nice money.
Money!
Oh, red herb.
Okay, red herb.
Here we go.
God, we have so many like...
the red and green herbs.
Even God can't defeat the final boss.
Oh, humanity at late stage capitalism.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, the humanity.
Not late stage capitalism.
Wait.
There's like a treasure here?
It's above me?
I knew it.
I knew it was above me.
God damn it!
Leon!
Why is your arm not long enough?
I'm so sad.
My arm is too short.
My two short arms.
Short King Leon.
Can I go through here?
No.
Oh my god.
Merchant.
Merchant!
2, 4, 5.
Okay.
5 of this... 5 gemstones of differing colors.
1, 2, 3.
I do!
Wait, you need a yellow round gem?
But I just need 2 circles.
2, 4, 5.
Yeah!
I could sell it for 2.0.
Don't... wait, don't... Oh, I can't!
God damn, I need a yellow!
I need a yellow gem.
I don't have a yellow gem.
I just realized.
I forgot there's... I thought... I don't know, it could be 2 different shades of red.
No, is that diamond?
Wait!
No!
I don't have enough Spinella!
God damn it!
I don't have enough Spinella.
I'm just... I'm just poor enough.
We were so close.
17... 18 hours?
No!
I must have AFK'd.
Oh, no!
It meant the time!
Wait, no.
I don't know.
I don't know if that was like the amount of time... hours I spent on this game.
Or if it's like the time right now.
How long did I AFK?
Lude above this door?
Where?
There's no lude.
Liar!
Oh, you mean this!
Where is it?
I hear it.
Oh, there he is.
There you go.
Yeah, that's good.
Alright, here you go.
Near the merchant?
There's more lude?
Or you meant that?
Oh, here!
This guy!
Okay, yellow.
God damn it.
Hey, at least I can sell this though.
I'll just sell this for now.
I just need the yellow.
I need the yellow diamond!
Okay, I'm saving anyway.
How come I have 5 reds?
Yeah, but I can have 2.0!
There must be another yellow diamond somewhere.
I'm not settling!
We're not gonna settle!
Uh, illustration... installation of the liquid nitrogen showers.
That were requested last month has been completed.
Liquid nitrogen is an extremely hazardous substance.
Exposure may cause blindness, frostbite, and even death.
Handle with care.
Oh wait, that's not good.
It says maybe, guys.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I like those odds.
Maybe is not guaranteed.
Okay.
It's not guaranteed.
It's a maybe.
What's this?
What does this do?
Hey guys, I figured out what the ma- See, I'm okay!
I told you it was a maybe!
What?
Guys, I told you it was a maybe.
I'm still okay.
Like...
See?
Didn't go blind!
May... May nine years since my awakening.
Upon release of this value...
Uh, black liquid shall enter my vein...
and circulate through my entire body.
I expect this will be the most painful experience of my life.
I await the trial with great anticipation.
It is an honor to suffer through the holy labor of rebirth.
The next time I awaken, it would be as the true servant of Master Ramon.
I make this vow.
I'll surpass the limitations of man...
and become a true servant of God.
I'll find the heretics...
and serve as their executioner.
Their vertigo.
Okay.
That scared me a little.
Not gonna lie when the gate closed behind me.
Oh hey, a lot of rifle ammo.
Wow.
Mm-hmm.
Is it him?
Are you the guy?
That's not the guy.
Alright.
I don't like this.
Oh!
I really don't like this.
I really, really do not like this.
I don't feel comfortable.
I don't feel comfortable here.
It's way too quiet.
Mm-hmm.
Hmm.
Oh, I think I know.
Okay.
Out of service appliances.
To conserve electricity.
The power has been turned off for some equipment, including the elevator.
It can be restored by flipping the circuit breaker located at the very back of the laboratory.
Where's that?
Here?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
I really don't like this.
Hello?
Oh.
Okay.
What?
What is this?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right, let me equip this.
Where are you?
Yeah?
Here?
Where are you?
Can I kill him?
With... with... bullets.
Okay, but can I kill him...
with bullets?
But you don't need to?
But he's a bullet sponge?
Okay...
Mmm...
Hello?
Oh my god, bro, fucking hell.
Fucking hell!
Where is he?
Hello?
Okay...
Where is he?
What is this?
Okay...
Oh...
Where?
I can take another hit.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh my god...
Go!
Okay...
Oh my god, I fucking...
God damn it!
It's just jump scares!
Is this a circuit breaker?
Power restored.
Thank fucking god.
Where?
He's in the walls now?!
Yes!
Kick!
Okay.
Okay, we can kill him!
It's possible!
What?
Looks like it's gonna take more than that.
Okay.
There's this.
I did...
I was like, oh no!
He bleeds!
Where is he?
Oh, no!
Oh no.
He's going to get me!
No!
He's gonna get me!
Headshot!
What is this?
He's going to, he's going to get me, he's going to get me!
Oh fuck!
Fuck off!
Huh?
Oh my god!
Seriously...
This is...
Are you serious?
Keep shooting!
He can die!
He can apparently die!
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Invade!
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh wait, where is he?
EVADE!
Where am I gonna kill you?
I'm gonna kill you!
You can die!
Apparently you can die!
AHHHH!
Oh god.
NO!
MY LEGS!
Okay.
It's okay.
EVADE!
You can die!
Allegedly!
What do you mean allegedly?
Oh god.
Is it Magnum time?
Where is he?
Oh!
There he is!
That's so fucked up!
Now he gets hit!
AY!
OH SHIT!
OOOH FUCK OKAY!
Yeah it's not, it's not, it's not, it's not, it's not, it's not, it's not...
OH MY GOD ARE YOU FUCKING... NO!
GET OUT!
Okay.
Come on.
HELP!
OH SHIT INVADE!
I did it.
Oh my god.
HOOOOOO!
We did it guys!
It only took my entire shotgun arsenal.
That's all it took.
Just all my shotgun ammo.
That's it!
It was just that simple.
It's just that simple.
Jesus Christ.
That was... That was scary.
Oh my god look there's more shotgun ammo!
It's like I never lost my ammo!
Here we go.
It's like nothing bad happened that day.
WOOO!
YEEEEEAAAAAAAH!
Guys thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the handsome bugmen for all the Doki content.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed my pure torture there.
Oh yeah I should grab that loot.
There's like loot right over here.
Holy fuck.
Jesus.
That was scary.
That was so fucking scary.
Alright.
OH NICE THE YELLOW!
I'm gonna go all the way back to the merchant.
I don't care.
I'm gonna go all the way back.
Wait actually...
Yeah I mean I could like save my game as well.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Nice.
Okay.
1.
2.
And then...
3.
And then the blue.
We got it!
We have so much money.
100k!
Let's fucking go!
We got 100k dollars!
Alright I could go to the elevator.
But like... money.
It's time for money.
That shit was so scary.
Jesus.
OH I FORGOT!
I'll go back there soon.
I need a...
I need a se- Wait.
Oh.
Where's the...
Where's the door?
Oh my god.
The door is locked.
Look at the door!
Are you serious?
He fucking destroyed my door!
What's wrong with you?
You monster!
Look.
Look I...
I could look over the murder.
But destroying my door?
That's fucked up though.
Yo.
That's fucked up.
I am okay with you fucking making an army of like murder suicidal bugs.
But destroying my door!
That's uncalled for.
That's so fucking uncalled for.
Alright he's near the elevator.
Oh thank god.
Okay I can sell.
Nice.
Alright.
Yeah so fucking rude.
Unforgivable!
That's alright.
We got the merchant here.
I'm looking at my arm.
I know it's pretty...
What about my legs?
Oh shit.
Oh my god he's in my heart.
Beautiful little lamb.
Your suffering came in.
Just as it has from you.
Oh ain't ci Tha Chuycan biggest pig ever find if your not.
Go to hell.
You can keep her.
Look if this is about Ashley.
You can keep going.
Oh, I can see what's going on!
I'm connected to the hive mind!
Bro!
Oh!
It's the homie!
Oh my god, it's the homie.
87%, nice.
Okay, shit.
Save.
I knew he wouldn't ditch me.
Bros for life.
My man!
Wait, that's it?
What the fuck did he do?
What happened in between?
What happened between these scenes?
How did you administer this?
I'm sorry.
It's the priority.
In that case, we know what we have to do.
Just homie stuff, you know?
You wouldn't understand, Dokie.
Princess Dulcinea!
You're gonna hurt yourself.
Hey, that was my lance.
Okay, we hurry.
I get it!
Why help me though?
Yeah.
What is it for you?
Can he die?
Can I just make him do everything?
You said I'd help you, didn't I?
Wait.
He's like free ammo.
Make your way to the surface.
Okay.
Let me get some ammo.
I need to know can I use him as a meat shield or can he die?
What a try.
I mean I can save ammo.
I can save ammo if he doesn't die.
Yes and no.
Homies never die.
True.
Rob, good job killing the bug god but did you know you could have froze him?
Look, it's not about... we're not here to make it easy.
Okay?
We're here to send a message to all the other bugs down there.
Today was the worst day of my life.
It's my daughter's fifth birthday.
But here I am stuck on a mangy boat heading out to some backcountry dump.
If it weren't for the pay, no one would be willing to work in the middle of nowhere.
Those in the... that's true.
That is true.
The pay is really really good.
I'm like... I can work anywhere.
Those in the castle are always reminding us to take care during the excavation.
A few workers collapsed after inhaling some dust.
Oh no.
Asbestos.
Oh no!
You're gonna get cancer!
There's something going on here but they're not telling us.
There's too many secrets.
I started coughing too.
I should sleep.
Something's really wrong with me.
I threw up blood three more times today.
And I'm so weak.
No!
He's getting it!
He's got the asbestos!
It's not OSHA safe!
Shit.
I never should have come here.
I came here for the money but instead I am the one paying the price.
I'm a terrible father.
I'm so sorry sweetheart.
You deserve better.
October since morning.
It don't work!
Why?
More blood threw up.
Many insects crawling.
I hear a voice.
A fine day to work.
Digging brings me so much joy.
I am full of happiness.
I offer it all to you.
Everything for you Lord Saddler.
Jesus Christ!
This is like cult!
Alright.
Trade.
Is there anything new?
Gold token?
Oh it's the prizes stuff.
Everything else is gold.
This is like not as interesting.
Alright.
Sell time!
Okay I can sell this.
This.
A gold frame monocle.
Okay yeah.
Oh my god I'm so rich now.
Oh my god now I'm double the tax bracket.
Alright.
Is there anything interesting that I don't have yet?
Uh striker.
Okay I don't need any of these.
What are the recipes then?
It said like new recipes.
I don't need any of the resources.
I have like plenty of shit right now so I can tune up.
Alright it's tune up time.
Okay my armor yes.
My armor is fucked up right now.
Uh I'm gonna upgrade my power for...
Uh let's see actually...
Power for...
I think power for the shotgun.
And then yeah I'm gonna upgrade the power for the shotgun.
And then the power for the pistol.
Uh yeah.
That should be good.
And then...
Oh I can upgrade the...
Oh I can fully upgrade all my guns!
I can upgrade all my guns.
Okay power on the riot too.
Yeah.
On the riot gun.
Okay and then...
I think we can...
We can start to slowly upgrade...
Uh...
Oh it's okay.
I still did it.
I might have accidentally got the guns confused but it's okay.
It still works.
Okay I guess I'll...
I feel like I used the shotgun more so I'm gonna do more...
I guess like reload for this.
Alright this is good.
We're good.
We should be good now.
I wonder...
I wonder if I can...
There's new guns to do this one.
I wonder what these guns are for.
Are there new guns for this?
New game!
Which one?
Is it this?
Red right?
Red...
Punisher...
Okay.
Watch this.
I have so much practice with this.
Why is it so slow?
Is it because of my gun upgrades?
Look at that.
No!
Okay so...
It's not fair!
I had to up-threaten the reload!
That's not fair.
What the fuck?
I don't have enough!
Okay.
Oh my...
What?!
Okay stop.
Stop.
Stop watching.
Oh I didn't shoot the TNT?
Oh!
That makes a lot more sense now.
That actually...
That actually makes a lot of sense.
Guys.
I don't know why I didn't think of that.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
Why?
Why is it that difficult?
Because...
What do you mean?
He fucking...
Are you serious?
Gamer of the year by the way.
Oh!
If it's...
It does like...
Oh!
I...
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't realize that's how they were gonna line up.
That's actually...
I didn't know this gun had like...
Go through people.
That's your luck!
There we go.
Nice.
That's good enough.
We don't need to do anymore.
Can we not?
You know.
That's fine.
We got three.
That's all we need.
Alright.
What is it?
Oh that's a grey.
Twenty...
God damn it.
Look!
It's cause the homie was watching me.
I got nervous.
Chat.
Don't you get nervous when the homie watches?
Yes.
The homie was watching!
Of course I got a little nervous!
Where the fuck is the...
Wait.
Was there...
Is there no like keyboard?
I mean not keyboard.
Sorry.
Oh.
Type.
I meant.
Is there no typewriter?
Yeah.
I got performance anxiety.
They went bankrupt.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Keyboard of the past.
Prehistoric keyboard.
Let's see...
I'm gonna go here, right?
Sub-objective.
So I can... I'm gonna go...
Go to the right side for now.
Oh wait.
What?
What's this?
Oh, I have to go to the right.
This is TNT.
The diamond has been relocated.
When using explosives, cave-ins are a frequent occurrence.
Keep your distance from the blast zone.
In the event of a disaster, clean up immediately.
Ensure adequate numbers of staff are on site.
Don't worry.
I'll definitely clean it up.
She didn't clean it up.
Alright.
Where the fuck are the... Where the fuck are the cult people?
Shoot them.
Oh, it's a villain!
Villagers!
I mean, what am I scared of?
I have my boy!
Okay, that is bullshit.
My boy is here.
Where is... I'm gonna shoot his leg.
Oh.
Alright.
Got his knees.
And then... There we go.
That's how I do the headshot there.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, vault.
There we go.
Nice.
It's fine.
We have the homies to help me out.
See?
Is that a chainsaw?
It's not a chainsaw, right?
It's not it, right?
There we go.
Did I hurt him?
Okay.
Oh, I didn't realize that didn't cross over.
That is my... Oh shit!
That's chainsaw man!
Oh shit!
It's okay.
That's why you're here.
Oh!
This is... What?
That was my kick!
I can't believe it.
Oh shit!
Okay, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
We're fine.
This is good.
Shoot him!
What the fuck?
It's okay!
Stab!
I've created my knife!
There you go.
Alright.
It's fine.
I upgraded my knife.
I can do that now.
Homie!
You're supposed to help!
Bro!
Oh shit.
Okay, stab.
Stab!
Nice.
Wait, you're still shooting somebody?
You know... Bro, it's fine.
Oh!
It was not fine!
In the end, it was apparently not fine.
Okay.
I have my legs for this.
Are they all dead?
They must be all dead, right?
Then I killed everybody.
Yeah, see?
I told you!
It's so easy!
Just kill everybody!
Heavy grenade?
Is it a heavy grenade?
Oh, fuck.
Wait, that's... Okay.
This is what this is for.
Alright, is he gonna drop down?
That's a woman, Chainsaw Man.
Alright.
There we go.
It's okay.
She can't see.
She has a bag on top of her.
That's fucking right.
Take off that bag!
You would have known I was here!
If she took off that bag, she could have known.
It was not very efficient.
She wasn't a very efficient Chainsaw Woman.
Man.
Alright.
Nice.
We got some ammo.
And then we open the door, wherever that is.
That's the bridge.
And then we...
Steal the key.
Steal their loot.
Oh!
What?
Where?
It's okay.
He's got this.
I'm just gonna open the door.
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
Why is he aggro to me?
There he is.
Shoot him.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
This is bullshit.
Bro!
Shoot!
What the fuck?
Bro!
I could have knifed him!
At least he's more... He is more useful than Ashley, though.
I have to admit.
Like, if only they could just give Ashley a gun.
Like, that's all Ashley needs.
She just needs a fucking gun.
The world would be easier if they gave a child a gun.
In game, by the way.
We're just gonna get rid of this guy.
Alright,
we're just gonna get rid of this guy.
Alright, he's dead.
Nice!
Don't...
PS.
Don't ever do that!
I said in game.
I am absolved of any legal matters by saying that.
Oops.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Gotta go this way!
Okay, there's a chest over here though.
Yay!
Golden Hourglass.
Nice.
That works.
Your honor, she said- OH SHIT!
Okay, look at that reflex though!
Oh my- Look at that flick though!
That's when you know I'm gaming.
That's when you know.
That was an insane flick.
That was a headshot flick too.
The gamer aim.
How do I get to the other side?
Wait a minute.
Do I go from above?
Yeah, fear makes me aim better.
Oh, I can!
Okay.
Oh, I think I can?
Yeah, I can just drop down.
Drop down!
Yay!
Here I go.
Alright, bro.
Let's go.
We gotta explode this.
Yes!
It's nice that they marked the stone for me.
It's like tic-tac-toe.
Oh, okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, okay.
Thank god.
It would be very unfortunate if he got crushed there.
You do not look like a researcher.
Yeah?
So average, guys.
So!
What an average guy working for Umbrella Corp.
Has the fucking cure for the larvae people.
So average.
Your average Joe.
Alright.
This way.
You just need to paint your pants yellow.
And Leon is ours.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Bro!
My arm's gonna get ripped off!
What?
You're gonna fucking be stronger than the troll?
Jesus Christ!
Now you owe me.
Oh, you!
No, no, no, no.
You made me get grabbed first.
What?
What do you mean?
Now you... There's two!
There's two!
Oh my god.
Where?
Where do I shoot?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Oh, there he is!
There it is!
Woo!
Gotta shoot the bike!
Okay, don't worry.
I got the rifle.
Oh.
That's unfortunate.
That's... Oh fuck!
That is...
Oh my god!
Where am I?
What happened to me?
Okay.
Here we go.
There we go.
Oh god.
Oh shit!
I gotta go up!
Melee!
Mike, thank you for the Akasu!
Fun!
Thank you!
Oh!
I got it!
One troll down!
I... He's dead?
Is he dead?
I can't tell.
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
How?
How do I?
Lewis!
Shoot him!
Where do I shoot him?
Where?
His head?
Okay.
Where do you think you're going?
Wait, yeah.
Where are you going?
Wait.
He's stuck!
He's not stuck anymore.
He's not stuck!
Guys, he was not stuck anymore.
Don't waste ammo!
Oh, God.
Shoot him!
Why me?
You have a better angle!
Okay.
Alright, let's finish this.
Why me?
You have a better angle!
We did it!
Yay!
We killed the troll!
Oh my God!
Yellow Diamond!
Jesus Christ!
Why the fuck?
I don't... Please, Lewis.
I didn't... You could have shot him!
You could have... Why did you make me shoot him?
You had ammo!
I know you had ammo!
You have unlimited handgun ammo!
This fucking freak.
I'm like, Leon!
Don't shoot your gun!
Distract him!
You guys said that.
That's all he had to say.
Alright,
loot.
Okay, there's some more ammo here.
Alright.
Nice.
And then...
Grenade here.
Let's see.
Wait.
Where is that grenade?
Oh, it's over here.
Wait, Lewis.
What the fuck?
And then...
Oh, it's nice!
Some ammo to sell!
Lewis, what are you doing?
Open this door!
Did he do it?
Am I supposed to go back?
Lewis.
Lewis, please.
I'm directionally challenged.
Oh, he did it.
Oh, thank God.
He actually did it.
He fucking did it.
What a madman.
What would win with a million...
Who would...
What would with a million dollars two trolls at the same time?
Thank you, Osus, for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh!
That's where they found it.
It's like...
It's like Jurassic Park.
They're trying to do another Jurassic Park.
But with like...
Like, scarier bugs.
Oh!
We're okay.
Can I make more... Oh yeah, I can definitely make more shotgun shells.
I swear I'm just making...
Why it's all just green herbs?
Please.
There's other colors in the world.
Alright.
Save.
Oh my God.
Leon, you don't understand.
It's the Razor Bro-Bot.
We're gonna be so close after this.
This is it.
This is the turning point of our relationship.
I have to shoot.
Oh no.
I have unlimited ammo.
What am I gonna be shooting?
Hehehe.
Going up the rails!
Okay.
I don't fucking... I don't know!
Ready the weapon?
Oh, okay.
Oh yeah.
Sweet strat!
This way?
We're gonna crash!
Wait, I...
I'm so confused.
What else?
What else is gonna come my way?
Is there anything behind me?
Hey!
The cart's flipping over!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
What the fuck is this minigame?
Hahaha!
What is this ducktail shit?
Like...
It's okay.
We're fine.
Get down!
Get down, Luis!
Oh my god.
At the lead and shoot!
Please!
What is your job?
What is your job, Luis?
Hahaha!
Jesus Christ!
I have to do everything.
Yeah, this is tempo of doom!
Hahaha!
Fucking tempo run right now.
We're in tempo run!
Alright.
Nice.
Dead.
What are you doing?
Get off the fucking rail!
Hahaha!
Wait, what if I just run him over?
Can I just run this man over?
Like, why was I so scared?
Why the fuck was I so scared of him?
My cart is...
My cart must have been stronger than this.
There's no way.
Yay!
Probably would grab the cart.
Bro, this cart is going like at least, okay, one mile per hour.
It's not that bad.
It's not that fast, but like, it should be fast enough.
It should have been fast enough.
That was easy.
Put the phone down and drive.
Yay!
Wait, he had dynamite?
Okay, I did not know he had dynamite.
Okay, you're right.
I would have died.
Now, if you told me he had dynamite, then that would make sense.
What the fuck?
What?
Where is he?
Oh!
What the fuck?
There's a door there!
Where the fuck did he come from?
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Wait, he's gonna explode himself!
Right?
Where is he?
Oh no, he's still alive.
Nice.
Alright, free loot!
Free loot!
Yay!
Wait, I hear...
Oh my god, thank god there's that.
Loot!
Okay.
Where's the...
I hear it, but where is it?
Is it above?
Above me?
Oh, it is.
I knew I heard you.
Fucking knew it.
I could always hear the loot.
Okay, shotgun.
Uh...
We have to go this way.
This way, Lewis!
This way!
Barrel!
Nice.
Oh my god, not again.
Alright, how about I drive and you shoot?
How about that?
Why don't we swap?
Hahaha.
Why do I have to shoot the gun?
I don't understand.
Oh god.
God, I'm trying my best!
You're not tilting!
Hahaha.
Oh fuck!
Okay, this is actually bullshit because I can tell that he was also not helping me.
Oh my god, there's two!
He was also not helping!
Do you not see that?
Hahaha.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Oh yeah, I see the dynamite now.
I never see it.
He's the moral support.
He's just takes cover.
Please.
Oh!
Please,
I know!
Louis, you have to help out too, Louis.
Like, please.
That's all I want.
Louis!
Louis, you shoot!
You shoot!
Ouch.
What the fuck?
What's that?
Okay, nothing was gonna come out.
I'm behind me.
That's good.
That's all I need to know.
I need to...
Jesus Christ.
Like, how?
Hahaha.
Oh shit, reloading.
Alright, it's fine.
Like, does he die?
Can I kill him?
Hahaha.
Hello.
Oh shit.
Same guy.
Please, I'm reloading.
Alright, we're fine.
Oh shit!
I don't know if you have a gun too!
Hahaha.
I just don't understand.
Why is he saving ammo?
Hello.
Nice weather we're having here.
Alright.
Nice.
We're alive.
I'm fucking moving as fast as I can.
Alright, nice.
We're alive.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh shit.
We're not, we're not, we're not!
I'm pushing!
Is that it?
Where?
I'm looking.
What's that?
There's a break.
Lewis, you have one job apparently!
Lewis!
You fucked up your one job!
That was literally the only thing you have to do!
Jump!
Hahaha.
I just did 99% of that work.
Lewis, can I get a hand?
The cards.
Give us a 3-2-1 next time, eh Sancho?
Get pussy.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, I don't know bro.
Look, look bro.
I know you're my best bro.
Even though we knew each other for like less than a day.
But bro.
Hahaha.
I don't know man.
Maybe my mom was right about you man.
I don't know if we could see.
I don't know if you can come under my house anymore man.
I...
Bro.
Give me a break.
We can make it if we circle around.
We circle around?
Oh I guess we...
No?
Where do we circle?
We drop down?
Where the fuck do we circle around?
Oh okay.
We drop down.
Sorry I didn't see the yellow paint.
The journalist yellow paint.
Alright, let's see.
There's a ladder here.
Ladder.
Here we go.
Alright bro, let's go.
Thank god you have gun though.
What the fuck?
Oh my god bro, shoot him!
Bro, shoot him!
Oh my god.
They're back?
Hahaha.
That's fucked up.
Wait.
Oh he shot someone.
That's fine.
My bro's got me, right?
Bro, you got me, right bro?
Okay.
He's got me.
Oh thank god!
Okay I can finally combine some herbs.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we have a lot of shit.
Too many have lost their lives in a never ending swarm of insects.
Please destroy the entrances in their gigantic hive and save us from further tragedy.
Okay but like, where?
Like how?
First up, where and also how.
Instructions unclear.
Do you think I double tap?
Woah!
Not wasting my ammo.
I know what to do!
Hahaha.
That's right!
I know what to do!
Hahaha.
That's right!
It's all me!
Stabbing time!
Stab!
Nice.
Where's the other one?
I swear I saw one more.
Where is it?
There you go.
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
That's fucking right!
Yeah I do!
Welcome to London!
Hahaha!
I hope you enjoy the king!
There you go.
Nice.
Is there more?
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?
He's like crawling now!
Get out of here!
Nice.
Alright.
I need a fucking...
Okay I actually have to use my gun now.
Hahaha!
I'm running out of like...
Uh... I'm running out of like...
I'm running out of knife juice.
My... There's almost no more knife juice guys.
My...
There's almost no more knife juice guys.
Alright.
We need to refuel our knife.
Okay let's see this way.
Destroy the hive...
I don't... Where's the hive holes?
I don't even know what it's supposed to look like!
Isn't that this?
Oh!
That's the hive...
It's yellow!
The journal!
Oh!
It's yellow!
The journal!
The journalist yellow!
I figured it out guys!
It's the journalist yellow again!
Hahaha!
It's always the journalist yellow.
Alright.
We figured out what it is.
Okay I'm gonna explode this cause...
Alright there you go.
Alright.
We figured it out.
My shoulder is hurting apparently.
Uh... The reason Lewis didn't shoot is because you're actually using his gun.
He didn't notice the swap because you're also using the same gun.
Oh!
That's why!
Oh shit!
Lewis!
I can't believe...
Lewis is... Why does he get...
Yeah he's an average guy.
But yet he gets unlimited ammo?
That's so fucked up.
Okay I thought that was a natural bug.
That's not fair!
Why does the average guy get unlimited ammo?
He can't be average if his gun is unlimited!
No thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright let's see...
Oh there's the last one.
Nice.
We did it.
We destroyed the hive holes.
Oh the holes are gone.
It's like popping a pimple.
Oh!
You know I'm just...
Can't be bothered to kick.
I have too much ammo.
Alright let's see...
Where does this way go then?
Oh wait this is where I'm supposed to go.
Alright let's see...
Yay money!
Just in case.
Yeah I fucking knew it.
I was like why is there a suspiciously placed...
uh...
suspiciously placed...
gas canister here?
Hmm...
Alright lights.
Where are they?
Where are the bugs?
You're a real rock.
I don't know man.
Is that actually a real rock?
Oh my god it was.
It was a real rock.
I can't.
I'm super paranoid now.
I can't believe it was real.
I can't believe it was real this entire time.
Alright get out.
There's more?
Okay I definitely don't need loot here.
Oh shit!
Get down.
Any more?
No?
Alright.
Nice.
Trying to make sure there's none that's like gonna fucking surprise me.
What?
Where'd he come from?
Oh shit!
That's where he came from!
I was like what?
What's that sound?
Any more?
Any more bugs?
Okay I got all the hives.
Alright up we go.
It's time to go up.
Bro.
You fancy.
I'm beat.
Makes you appreciate tech like these.
I don't get you.
Why risk your life like this?
Puppies!
You don't know us.
I told you.
I passed the merchant?
Be strong.
You were straight with me for once.
Los Iluminados.
I was working for them.
See?
There was a hole?
Helping the two of you doesn't make up for it.
I know that.
But still.
I don't want anyone else to get hurt.
In that case, you better get serious.
Harsh words for a squire.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I missed out on the merchant.
Gus.
We made it all this way.
You know it means we're almost...
Almost what?
Louis!
Oh shit, it's this guy!
Long time no see.
What the fuck?
Bro, that was my job!
No, I used my knife on the fucking bugs!
Bro, my knife's gonna break!
It's gonna touch his skin and break!
This reminds me of the Resident Evil gunfight where you just run around and then nothing happens.
We fight with the kitchen knife.
We are just getting started, rookie.
Wait, do I actually have to fight with- are you fucking kidding me?
Fuck!
Bro, my knife is about to break!
I used it on the bug!
Why didn't anybody stop me?
Bro!
Why didn't anyone stop me?
Bro, I actually used the majority of my fucking- Bro, I actually used the majority of my fucking- Bro, I'm- Bro, my fucking knife, bro!
Okay, pause.
Wait,
what the fuck?
Where did he go?
Oh shit!
How?!
Right here.
I can understand what happened was unforgivable.
Oh!
Nice!
Break free!
Come on, I'm trying to take you to the edge!
I'm assuming that I can like just kick you off!
Yes!
Yeah!
Okay.
I don't know.
My knife?
That's a- Yes!
No, I can't!
God dammit!
You're alive!
You mean I could shot my gun this entire time?
Bro,
bro, bro, his thighs are thicker than mine's.
Bro...
Why didn't you warn me that knives weren't for bugs?
It's not the ladies that are gonna be at loss.
It's not just the ladies, bro.
Bros before os.
You know, I led a pretty shitty life.
But now, hey?
What do you think, Leon?
People can change, right?
No, bro!
Bro!
I thought he was gonna hold his hand.
He's just kidding.
I was like, damn, what did happen during that cave time?
Holy shit, what happened in that cave?
Alright.
I bet the accuracy is from the fucking...
It's from the knife fight.
One last moment.
Alright, next.
Okay, you just ruined...
I improved the moment.
Secret cave video.
I did it.
Alright.
Let's spend one...
Let's look at him while I use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
Sheep!
Luka and Aiden!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
He's just...
He's just faking it, guys.
See, there's no blood.
He's just having a rest.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She's not looking right now.
I hold hands with all you dragoon pros.
Yeah.
Yeah, not looking, by the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I think it's time to actually fix the...
I think it's time to fix my inventory a little bit.
Let me...
Alright.
There you go.
I have like two spaces.
Don't...
My...
God.
I can't believe I wasted my knife...
in the fucking bugs.
Why didn't you guys say anything?
None of you said anything!
Oh my God.
Alright, up we go.
Alright.
Up we go.
We don't need the merchant.
Shit, we have gun.
You did not ask.
A friend?
Ashley?
Bro!
I don't want to be friends with like...
Yeah, you have to be very careful of your wording right now.
I...
Leon is like 20 something.
Ashley is like a tween.
I don't want to be a friend with a tween.
This is a job!
Ada!
This is a job, Ada!
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh, hey.
Uh...
Let's see from the... even the very sight of his image makes my... she's in college?
She does not look like... bro!
I think it's because of the skin I have.
She looks like... I...
She's wearing Hot Topic shit.
Like I assume she's a...
She's a tween.
Like...
Okay.
It's the Hot Topic, guys.
Even the very sight of his image makes my skin crawl.
Do me a service and find some way to deface the portrait of him in the room shown in the photograph.
Will you?
It's not particular how hard you do it.
Hitting it with something might do the trick.
Ramone's portrait.
What the fuck is this?
I don't know what this is.
Someone help me recover a stolen jewelry.
A jewel snatched by a thieving crow.
I bet it can be found in the vile things nest.
It's an heirloom of our family.
It cannot become some kid's...
Oh, it's in the courtyard.
Okay.
I see you took care of a request.
Yeah, I did.
It's in the throne room?
Alright, it's the throne room.
Yay!
Okay, I can get rid of this.
And this.
Okay, bro, I have so much stuff to sell.
Oh, I should do that real fast, too.
Uh...
Gemstones...
I can put two... Actually, I should put the blues.
Actually, no.
Two of the reds.
Actually, one of the reds?
I'll do two of the reds.
Do I do the reds?
No, I think I can do...
I don't know.
I feel like I can put like all of the kind of...
Alright, let's plug it.
I'll do two of the reds.
Alright, I'll sell this.
And then I'll sell...
Uh...
Keep a chicken... Does it look like I have...
I've seen some chickens here?
I don't think there's any chickens near me.
Okay, we don't need the submachine gun ammo.
We don't need...
the bolts.
And I think that's everything?
Oh my god, I have nine of these?
Eh, it's fine.
Maybe one day.
One day I'll use it!
One day...
Let's craft a chicken.
Umm...
Let's see...
I'm gonna...
grab the reload speed up...
Let's see...
I'm gonna...
I feel like I'm gonna up the power.
Whenever we get to the boss fight, this would be useful.
Alright, save game.
Nice.
Oh.
Oop!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Alright, where's the throne room?
It's all the way over here?
Locked treasure.
Oh, fuck.
Let's go.
I might as well.
I mean...
There's no way there's people here, right?
I killed everything.
Right?
Yeah, I should have killed everything.
I'm pretty sure.
Uhh...
What was the other mission I have to do?
I have to kill something.
I did.
I fixed the knife.
See?
It's fixed already.
Oh yeah!
The pawn!
I gotta find the pawn too.
Where's the area?
Oh, it's over here.
Is that the... yeah.
The throne room.
Alright.
We need to get the emerald in the courtyard.
And then the...
Uhh...
I think I fixed the portrait here.
We might as well get that over with.
It might be useful.
Later.
Oh, hey there.
Hey guys.
I'm just gonna...
Oop.
Alright.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
I didn't know you were here too!
Woah!
Shit!
They can't go through the door!
I win!
It's fine!
They can't...
They're afraid of the door!
Nice.
Don't you love it when they can't walk through the door?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
They do?
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
My shoulder!
Run!
What the...
Alright.
It's fine.
How is the door still open?
It just works.
Oh hey, there's a vase here.
Boop!
Nice.
All the ammo I used earlier.
Alright.
Time to deface this portrait!
Hello.
Surely there's nobody in this room, right?
Surely, right?
Surely I'm safe, right?
Right guys?
Mmm...
Chicken!
Oh my god, I have to get an egg!
What, it's two chickens?
Why are there so many chickens?
Chicken!
My lord, my true benevolent father, blessed the Salazar bloodline with an iron hammer.
The founder of my family proclaimed the holy teachings of lust, evil, and persecuted its followers.
Not only that, he stole their most prized possession and sealed it below the castle.
Blasphemy!
Insolence!
How long have I suffered the shame of knowing that the same blood flows through my veins?
Finally, the day of atonement has come.
Oh my beloved Lord Saddler, I shall release the holy plagues that were hidden under the castle.
The time is now.
With divine grace, the wicked shall be reborn as a part of the flock.
Reborn as Ganado!
They shall be my lord's loyal servants.
Nothing will please me more than to sit at my lord's feet and bask in your splendor.
I am your humble servant.
You are my eternal light.
To you, I swear my unwavering allegiance.
Chicken!
Is this it?
Did I do it?
Is this his family?
Oh, this is his family!
Why can I...
Am I not defacing it?
Why isn't it...
Oh, it's the egg?
Oh wait, I don't know if I should be sitting here.
Hmmmm...
Thank you, chicken.
Okay, thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay, equip.
Alright.
There we go.
Thank you, chicken.
For letting me eat that egg.
I really appreciate it, chicken.
Oh, Master Ramon!
For tomorrow's procedure, I shall finally surpass the limitation of this mortal shell.
What's left of me now shall soon be gone.
Magnificent!
The holy body is a wondrous miracle.
The felty has sworn to Master Ramon is the soul of the world.
The soul light that illuminates my path.
Our fate shall be entwined until the very end.
Have you ever known such loyalty?
Alright, do you have the golden egg?
Chickens, can you lay me the golden egg?
Apparently, this is very important.
Does it have to be golden?
Can it be any type of egg?
Does it have to be a golden egg?
It has to be golden?
Where the fuck... Lay your fucking eggs.
Lay your eggs!
Paint it yellow.
Alright, I'll do this puzzle.
It has to eventually lay the egg while I do this puzzle, right?
Eventually, it'll start laying eggs.
Okay, that's not it.
No, that's not it either.
This?
No.
God damn it.
Is it this one?
No.
Okay.
This one.
Here.
Oh, there's the golden egg!
Alright, I'll throw this one.
Alright, can you lay a regular egg?
Or...
Because I don't want to use my golden egg.
Can you guys lay regular egg?
Okay, if I sit in here, will you guys lay this egg for me?
Alright.
Chicken.
Where are you, chicken?
Where are you?
Yeah, but what if I can just throw a regular egg?
Why do you guys have performance anxiety?
Why now?
Alright, we'll save the golden egg.
I'm totally gonna miss.
Guys, I want a backup egg just in case.
What if I miss?
What?
Guys, you know it could happen.
You know I might accidentally miss.
You miss just miss.
Lay the egg!
Sit down!
Lay your egg!
Sit!
Oh, oh, it's gonna do it!
It's gonna do it!
It's gonna do it right here!
Lay that egg.
Come on.
Oh!
Get out!
Alright.
Okay, now I won't miss.
Guys, I have a practice throw.
I have a practice throw.
Does a normal egg work, guys?
Does it have to...
Do normal eggs work, chat?
Acting like the chicken is a dog.
No!
It has to be...
gold?
God damn it.
Okay, guys.
We're gonna use the brown egg as a practice throw.
Just in case.
I don't know!
I have a feeling...
I'm stupid!
I can miss!
What if I miss?
Alright, what was the other mission?
I already forgot what the other mission was.
Okay, request.
Which one have I not completed?
Okay, jewel thief.
Snatch... Oh my god!
I need to find...
Shit!
I killed all of you!
Oh my god!
How are you still alive?
Did I not kill all of you?
Oh, there's more.
That's why.
There's more.
How did you guys show up?
Oh my god!
I didn't miss, guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Double tap.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
At least that's free money.
Alright.
Down here...
And then there's...
The courtyard.
Alright, time to get that...
Is it just one crow?
Chat?
How many...
Is the crow easy to find?
That's my biggest question.
That's what I'm worried about.
Alright, let's save just in case.
It's in the nest?
It's around the merchant area?
Which one?
This one?
The courtyard's right in front of me.
That's you, isn't it?
That wasn't that crow.
Guys, it wasn't that crow, guys.
You don't even have loot!
This crow doesn't even...
It doesn't even have loot!
It's not loot crow!
I was supposed to follow him!
Oh, oh he's back alive!
He's alive again!
He's alive!
It was just a flesh wound!
Guys, I told you.
It was just a flesh wound, guys.
It's okay.
He was just being dramatic, chat.
He lives!
Bird Jesus!
It was just a flesh wound, chat.
I knew I couldn't...
It wasn't my fault.
Oh, give me that fish.
Give me that...
Big bass.
Okay.
Alright.
There's another one.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Alright, this is a little dirty here.
Okay.
Let's see.
Okay, I need to look how much...
Alright, we're gonna figure...
We're gonna figure this out.
We can Tetris this.
We're gonna figure...
This out.
Let's see.
I'll just mix all the green herbs.
I'll do that.
There we go.
Oh.
Bum ba da dum.
Ba da dum.
Ba dum ba dum.
Bum bum.
Bum ba dum.
There we go.
See, I told you.
I told you guys.
Wait, is that another fish?
No.
Doki, you have a problem.
You gotta get rid of all this fish.
You can't keep...
killing all the fish, Doki.
Yeah, I already got the beta.
And I sold it for money instantly.
Alright, let's go...
Let's go turn in this...
quest.
Yay!
Trade.
I have 10.
Let's see.
Nah, there's nothing I need.
Save game.
I can't believe it.
We met Bird Jesus.
What an honor.
What a fucking honor.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
He came back to life in front of all of us.
It was a miracle.
Which way?
This way?
No, it was like within here.
A fucking miracle.
A miracle!
Yeah, I can sell it here.
I'll sell the emerald here.
Alright, hello.
I'm back.
Sell the scratch emerald here.
Yay!
I look like I'm selling his own fucking emerald back to him.
I sold it back to him.
But you shot him?
That's what the media wants to see.
That's fake news.
That's fucking fake news.
I can't believe you got brainwashed by the media.
I would never!
I would never shoot Bird Jesus.
That's not something Doki would do.
Hey, some more money.
Money!
Alright.
Deceived by fake news.
How could you guys believe in those things?
Tsk, tsk, tsk!
Thought I taught you guys better!
Up we go!
Oh my god, there is a lot of loot here.
What the fuck?
Whose statue is that?
That's him!
Bird vs.
Bird pilots.
I'm telling you, Mr. Kennedy.
However, I'm afraid it ends here.
Expel this intruder!
It's the guy!
Don't worry.
I got my pistol right here.
It's fine.
I can just stay here.
I don't have to move.
I'm not scared.
Look at that.
If I stay here, they'll just... I don't have to move.
Watch.
This is the no move run.
No move run right here.
Reloading first.
Reloading.
There you go.
Is there anymore?
I see you.
Wait.
What the f... What?
Okay, wait, wait.
I see you.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Where is he?
Oh, I see you.
That's fucking right.
I don't have... Okay, I moved.
Doesn't count.
I'm technically still in the same spot, chat.
Is that it?
That was fast.
Is there no more?
Come down!
Cowards!
Oh my god.
They're gonna make me walk all the way to them now?
That's fucked up.
How could they do this to me?
Oh, there's loot though.
Alright, they don't come over to me!
That's not my fault!
How could I do the no move run if they don't move either?
Like...
How does no move run work if they don't move?
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
Alright, I'm just gonna... I'm gonna shoot their toes.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
There we go.
Let me grab that barrel.
And then... any other loot here?
That should be it.
Wait!
There's a mini guy.
Nice.
Alright.
There we go.
Up we go.
Where are they?
Hello?
Monks?
Cult followers?
I hear you whispering.
Oh, there you are.
Nice.
That's all...
No, that's not a crit.
There you go.
I mean, it's not so bad being a fucking cult member.
Like, look at that.
Like, if I can tank, I'll never be afraid of dying!
Like, think about it.
You'll never be afraid of dying because you can just tank like six headshots.
What the fuck?
Oh, he burned too.
Okay.
He was helping me.
He was helping.
Okay, you think about it the flamethrower was helping me.
Okay, maybe I can just stay here.
Oh, I can stay here.
Yeah, I'll be fine.
If I don't move, they'll just burn this guys.
Yeah.
I don't have to move.
What the fuck?
I don't even see this guy.
Come on.
There's no way he's fast.
Oh, he's faster?
There you go.
Give me a sec.
I just want to make sure that he's dead.
Before I do anything.
C'mon.
What?
There you go.
All right, here we go.
I'm ready.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
Oh shit!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Kick, kick, kick, kick!
This was important!
Okay, kick!
Wait, what?!
What the fuck is that?!
Oh shit!
Where is that coming from?!
No, not the fire!
Where is it coming from?!
Is it gonna come towards me?
Oh, it's gone.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
It's just one, right?
Oh, it is not just one!
It's not just one spiky boss!
Why is there multiple spiky boss?!
Nooooooooooo!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Okay, thank God.
I thought there was like more spiky boss.
Nothing to worry about.
Nooooooooo!
Get me in the hole!
Okay, I'm in the hole.
Alright, it's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
I'm in the hole.
Alright.
Oh, I can eat my fish now!
Slightly large bread as an eating fish.
Okay, I need to eat the fish.
I need to eat the fish.
Okay, when is the next ball coming over?
Is that it?
There's no more balls?
Okay, we gotta wait for this ball to drop out.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Can I outrun this other?
Okay, yeah, I can.
Fucking bitch.
Bitch.
What?
Okay!
Okay, I don't know.
I thought like, you know...
I don't know.
I thought he would just let me stab him.
I didn't realize he's just gonna watch me.
Like, how was I supposed to know he's just gonna grab me?
He stood still!
I thought I was safe because he stood still!
Wait, can they even get up?
No, they can't.
Where are they gonna go?
They can't even... What?
How are they gonna get to me?
God, it is...
Oh!
He... They... They...
They're walking to me!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I...
He has to drop down, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
Alright, free loot.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
That's someone changing!
It's okay.
They're not... They don't know how to fall down.
Free loot.
No, we're gonna hoard our grenades until the...
Until the next game, chat.
You know the drill.
We're all gonna hoard.
We're gonna hoard until the... Until Resident Evil 5.
It's not wasting ammo!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Can I like shoot this and grab it here?
Yeah, I can.
Wait, I can.
That's so nice.
Alright, that's good.
I can... I can just grab it like that.
Wait, there is...
There's a treasure here somewhere.
Where is it?
Where's the treasure?
Huh?
Where the fuck... Oh, it's right here!
How do we get there?
Oh, wait.
It's above me.
It's not a waste, chat!
It's not a waste!
Nice herb.
Because wasting grenades is a bigger waste.
Think about it.
Alright.
F.
Wait, there is more stuff here.
Oh, I'm gonna go up!
Where?
Oh, shit.
There!
Where?
I can't see!
I can't see!!!
Okay.
We're gonna shoot it here.
Oh god!
There you go.
We got him.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, god.
Does that hit him?
Doesn't it hit him?!
This is bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh, god.
God.
Get out.
Get out!
Is he dead?
He must be dead.
Oh shit!
Where did you come from?
Okay.
Dodged.
Chink.
Kick you out of here!
You know what?
Chink.
Kick!
There we go.
You know what?
I don't even need a waist...
Oh shit!
You know what?
Fuck this.
Chink.
It's fine.
We don't need... It's fine!
Just stab!
There we go.
I told you it's fine.
We don't need guns in this house.
Anything can be a weapon.
Okay, I need a fucking craft shotgun ammo.
Stabbing will always work!
Alright.
How did I waste ammo?
Just keep stabbing.
Whoa.
Fuck.
Alright.
Oh.
What's this?
At the entrance?
Is that it?
You think I can land my egg throw here?
Bro, I'm gonna miss... I know I'm gonna miss the throw.
It's gonna be like so fucking sad.
Recycle!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
It's been a busy week for me.
That can only be a VOD game.
But I finally chased all the VODs that can watch you live!
Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat.
Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
It's okay.
You're gonna watch me finish this game today.
This way.
Bomb.
Whoa.
Okay, we don't look down.
We'll be fine.
BOMB!
Guys, we weren't fine.
Guys.
Guys, we were not fine.
We were not fine.
Guys, I looked down.
Guys.
Okay.
Okay, we don't run.
Now we know.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Okay.
We walk.
We're walking now.
We've learned our lesson.
Jesus Christ.
Here we go.
We learned our lesson.
We walk.
And then we grab this too.
Yay!
Okay.
We walk.
We walk so we don't die.
Wait, what?
You're still alive?
Are you still alive?
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Alright, nice.
Oh, thank God you have yellow herbs.
Oh!
We can actually make shit.
Alright.
I need a cell.
This and then...
Oh shit, nope.
And then...
Wait, actually we can...
Let's just combine this for now.
I have a red one.
Red and also a red.
That's double, right?
Yeah.
Times two.
1.2.
Yeah, the double reds.
Alright.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Boop.
Uh, tune up.
Okay.
Repair our knives because we've been fucking around too much with that.
We've been messing around with that a bit too much.
Alright.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see.
We have to repair.
You know what?
Let us...
Let us power up our knife.
And then we'll upgrade our...
We'll upgrade our shotgun actually.
Ammo capacity.
There we go.
Save.
Alright.
Fine.
Everything's fine.
Up we go.
I don't think I have enough to max this.
I don't think I have enough to max the knife yet.
I'm like so poor.
I'm pretty sure.
Do I have enough to upgrade the knife?
Let me double check.
So...
Oh no.
Tune...
No.
Tune up.
Uh...
Oh, I can!
I can full upgrade it.
Increase attack...
Guys!
Okay, but like...
Do I need to?
Guys, I'm ready to save up for this.
I'm gonna save up for the magnum.
I feel like...
Because I feel like I'm not gonna...
I'm gonna use that more in the end.
Because...
Oh, I missed the box up here?
How could I miss a chest?
Yeah, what the fuck do you mean?
I got everything.
What do you mean?
There's no painted yellow.
That thing's painted yellow.
Believe in the power of the shank.
Yeah, I'm saving up for the boss fight!
That's why I don't use it!
It's all about the boss fight's chat!
It's about the boss fight.
I'm investing...
For long term.
And so I have delivered the girl to you as promised.
Bye, girl!
Oh shit.
Don't worry!
I have a fucking egg!
Shoot the head Leon!
Oh!
I told you!
Shoot the head!
That should have been your first shot Leon.
Oh man.
That's not a bad thing down there.
Surely it's nothing dangerous.
Egg and then magma.
If you miss.
I'm gonna miss.
Okay.
This is it!
I missed.
I missed!
How?
I told you!
I told you I needed practice eggs!
But nobody believed me!
Nobody believed me when I said I needed a practice egg!
None of you thought I needed a practice egg!
Why did no one ever believe me?
Anything is possible!
You know anything was possible!
I can miss!
What would others think of you?
I can't believe it.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry doing it!
It's too late!
We have to accept our consequences!
Guys!
We have to accept our mistakes chat!
We can't just reload it whenever we want.
It's not.
We can't just Baldur's Gate this!
Ha!
Ahahaha!
I can't believe I missed.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I fucking missed.
Oh my god, I can't believe I fucking missed the egg.
How?
How did that happen?
What do you mean?
Look, this is a group effort chat.
This is a group effort.
You didn't give me enough information.
I can't believe it.
You could have given me more information.
It's not my fault.
I was going in there with a lack of info.
The lack of intel chat.
This is a group effort chat.
We both fucked up together.
We fucked up together chat.
Alright, here we go.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Since when was this a group effort?
The contract is subscribing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta figure this out now.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna put this here.
And then here we go.
Alright, nice.
We have another kitchen knife.
No, the contract is watching the stream chat.
When you watch the stream, that's the contract.
That's the contract.
By being here, you've signed.
Okay.
Let's see.
We're fine.
It's fine.
We killed him.
Lord Corrosus, hit the target five feet away from you.
Instructions unclear.
Mistake.
You guys could have told me to get closer.
I didn't know it was five feet.
I was six feet away chat.
You guys should have said five feet.
I would have walked up a little bit.
And that is why.
This is a group mistake.
I was lacking information to walk closer up to get closer.
And because of that...
No, no, no.
If you told me it was within five feet, I would have walked closer.
I was within six feet.
I was six feet away.
I was six feet away chat.
I did not count for the wind.
I also did not account for the wind.
How was I supposed to know the wind was going to change the trajectory of my egg.
And then there's the weight of the Golden Egg as well.
Golden Egg is heavier than a normal egg.
And...
I should have been painted yellow.
I have failed you my Lord.
OK.
I was unable to fulfill your final commandment and keep the boy from the path of wickedness.
I caught a glimpse of Master Ramon's evil temperament during his younger years.
When he discovered a servant mocked him by uttering whatever the fuck this is behind his back.
He summoned her to his private chambers.
After forcing her to kneel before him, Ramon dosed her face with a viral overt ritual he pulled out of his pocket.
The young master watched with glee when the servant writhed in agony as the skin melted from her face.
His twisted grim still haunts my dreams this very day.
As time passed, Ramon's treachery only deepened, and the infernal cult soon learned they could prey upon his vulnerable heart.
Curse the fiends!
They manipulated Master Ramon and turned him into their puppet.
Worst of all, they managed to use him to unleash the les plagas that the Salazar family has fought so long and hard to keep sealed away.
Lord Diego, rest assured, I intend to watch over Master Ramon until the very end, whatever fate may befall us.
As a faithful servant of the Salazar family since birth, it is my duty and my penance to you.
Alright, pretty sure that housekeeper is dead.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sounds like grade S copium.
Look, it is not my fault that the...
That the fucking gold egg is heavier than a normal egg, chat.
That is not my fault.
How was I supposed to know that the gold egg was heavier and thus changes the grip of my egg?
So like I ended up throwing it too...
Too...
I ended up throwing it too lightly.
I didn't compensate my strength.
To throw a golden egg.
I didn't account.
I didn't figure out... I couldn't figure out the math in my head.
I used like normal egg in my head.
He is dead.
I am looking for the key.
Yeah, I am looking for the key.
Yeah, I did it.
I think this has to be my worst day.
10% of that was from the egg throw.
That is where the egg was.
Alright, nice.
1N, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We are not responsible for final calculations of the employer.
Only the first estimate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But I don't think I will get a straight answer.
Yeah, she doesn't care about you.
She is only here for the money.
You know after the incident, the world changed.
Maybe if you used more grenades, you would have more experience with the weight of a metal shaped object.
Leon S.
Kennedy.
You haven't changed.
You just think you have.
So here is my question.
Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you changed?
You will never be able to punch rocks with a whimpy throwing arm like that.
What do you think?
This is why I don't punch rocks.
I kick them.
We are here.
See those thighs?
If I could have kicked the egg, I would have made it.
She called me handsome.
See you later.
Oh my god.
New girlfriend.
Right there.
Story of my life.
Guys, it's because I didn't kick the egg.
That was my problem.
If I could have kicked the egg, I would have hit it.
I would have hit the target.
New old girlfriend.
That was the issue.
Wait, is that a machine gun?
Okay,
that's a lot of machine guns.
Can I...
Okay, this is a lot of machine guns.
Okay, can I just snipe them from here?
Yeah, I can, right?
How the fuck did that man live through that?
Okay, nice.
Well, I got this guy out.
I knew I should have had a second...
I knew I should have had a third egg.
I knew...
I fucking knew I needed a third egg.
I knew it.
You guys were like, no, you just need one egg.
And I was like, no way.
Can I like just destroy it?
I can't shoot it?
How the fuck do I get out?
How the fuck do I not die from this?
I just have to walk the other way.
I can't believe it.
I can't just shoot things.
This is so fucked up.
I can't just shoot it.
What's the point if I can't just shoot it?
Oh, it's a merchant.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, it's a merchant!
Is there anything else?
Oh, I need that, actually.
Good thing I saved up.
That's good, I saved up there.
Anything new?
The killer.
My pistol is still the best pistol, right?
64.
Okay, we need the case.
And yeah, I think that's all we need.
Oh, Killer7 is the magnum?
Okay, I can't afford it though.
I can sell this now.
Okay, nice.
And I can sell this too.
Alright, bye!
I'm gonna buy the case upgrade.
Okay.
Do I have junk?
Oh, I do.
I have ammo I don't need.
Uh, flash grenade... first aid...
Okay, never mind.
I don't.
Everything is useful.
Sell Ashley.
I don't even have Ashley anymore!
There's treasure here.
Bats.
Nice.
Treasure.
Treasure time!
Nice.
Woop!
Okay, can I... where is it?
Where the fuck's the treasure?
Treasure?
I'm looking up.
Is it down?
Where the fuck's the treasure?
Hello?
Oh, it's here!
How do I look at that?
Oh my god, do not throw the nade.
How the fuck do I...
What?
How did I read that?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's for later?
Oh, okay.
Where the fuck is that treasure?
Tres-throwing the egg.
Not everything needs to be in the treasure chest.
I'm gonna throw an egg.
Will it be fine if I just kill him here?
There you go.
Okay, there he is.
I can just...
Woah!
He got back up!
It's fine.
I can literally just stay here.
They just come to me.
Oh my god.
Okay, they're all...
They're all insect heads.
I'm gonna go ahead and just throw the heads.
This is it!
This is your chance to practice throwing!
I don't need practice to throw.
I do it every day.
Oh, fuck!
What?
Now they know I...
Guys, you're trying to tell me I was supposed to do this stealthily?
There's no way.
There's no way this was supposed to be done stealth-wise.
This is it!
There's no way I was supposed to do this stealthily!
Who would've thought?
Chat, this is where all the nays are for.
This is it, guys!
I told you it was useful!
It was useful!
I knew it!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Can I just kill him from here?
Here we go.
It's fine.
I can kill him from here.
Oh, he's dead.
That was it.
That's it.
See?
Look, I didn't waste any ammo.
Look at that.
I told you!
See?
Look at that!
I knew that egg throw...
That egg throw made me better at egging people.
I like to think throwing those eggs made me better at throwing grenades.
That was the practice.
That was what was for practice.
I am so fucked.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Are you still... there's still people?
There we go.
There, he can burn.
He's not burning?!
What the fuck?!
Oh, there it is.
Alright, here we go.
Woop.
There we go.
That's another 10% gone!
Easy, easy.
It's okay.
It's...
It's like... It's handgun ammo.
We're fine.
It's handgun ammo.
We'll be fine.
We don't have to worry about handgun ammo, chat.
We're so healthy.
We're so fucking healthy.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna go this way.
I think I killed everybody.
I think everybody's just dead.
Woop.
Did I just kill everybody?
Nice.
Wait, how the fuck...
How do I get over there?
Did I disable it already?
I can't tell!
See, look!
I got back some handgun ammo!
It's like I didn't waste them!
It's like I never wasted it at all!
Can I get through here?
I can't tell if it's scanning me or not!
Man, that would've been nice to shoot at.
Oh, wait!
There's a treasure behind me!
Where's this treasure?
It's like right here?
Oh, here it is!
Nice.
See?
If I didn't kill everybody, I wouldn't have been able to loot freely, chat!
Look at that!
Now, I can loot as much as I want!
See?
This had to be done!
I wouldn't be able to do all this looting!
Why is this yellow?
Oh, that was originally...
It's just... actually was supposed to be yellow.
Alright, is there anything up here?
Oh, ammo!
Look at that!
Never punished!
I got ammo right here!
Never punished at all!
Okay, it's like this way.
Of course I'm right!
Oh yeah, the Doki way.
I told you!
The Doki way is always the right way!
Now, where am I?
We're on the island.
Okay, how do I get across from this?
I have to...
go from here...
Oh my god, no!
Not from here!
I'm getting lost!
How do I get lost?
How?
How do I... How?
How do I walk from there?
Uhhh...
Go all the way back?
Like this?
Oh, okay, here we go!
Sorry, I had to use my brain for once.
I can't shoot my way out of this.
God damn it!
I actually had to think.
Oh, the misery.
I can't believe it.
Thinking.
I can't just shoot my way out of everything.
So sad.
Not...
How could you say that?
Everything can be shooting if I try hard enough!
I can't believe you would say such a thing!
Okay, let's see.
Whoa!
Let's see.
What the fuck I did?
Why did you hear me?
It can't be my gun, right?
No, not this guy.
Okay.
I'll make sure he doesn't get close to me.
Oh, reloading.
Don't get close to me.
Okay, I'm gonna use this.
Hahaha!
That...
That I heard is a one-shot, so I don't wanna risk that.
I'm not risking the one-shot guy.
Oh, he has a helmet.
I can still shoot you in the face.
Nice.
Okay.
I can tell when you're dead because you...
You fall down.
And you drop loot.
Damon, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Is there anybody above me before I go up?
Here's somebody up top.
I had to say this at least once.
You're amazing.
Don't ever change.
Thank you, I know I'm perfect.
The Doki way.
I could sneak up, but then I could do this!
Oh!
The rain covered my running.
Raps, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
That's what I called a pro gamer.
Exactly!
This is how gamers play this game.
Where are they?
I hear them.
Oh, there he is.
Oh shit, crit!
Nice.
Good crit.
There's like one more.
Somewhere.
Where is this?
Holy shit, what the fuck is this map?
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
He just stood there!
What are you doing in this corner?
Bro!
It wasn't even like a hiding spot.
You just stood there.
He wasn't even hiding.
That's like the worst part.
He just stood there.
Like, honestly.
What was the point?
He's just chillin'.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, we can combine it.
Alright, here we go.
He's pissing.
He was trying to use the bathroom.
Does it look like there's any toilets here?
But why in the cave?
Like, help the bushes grow or some shit.
Like, I don't know.
Like, why waste the liquid?
On the rock!
Let me shoot the legs.
Wait, what the fuck?
Shoot the toes?
Alright.
Here we go.
I'll shoot the legs here.
It's fine.
Shoot the leg.
Nice.
Wait, what?
Behind me?
Oh, wait, no.
It's him.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Alright, there you go.
Gotta make sure.
He's a fan of erosion.
He's trying to make some diamonds.
You don't understand.
A rocket launcher?
What the fuck?
Yeah, this is not good at all.
Wait, where is the rocket launcher guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We're gonna make sure.
I'm gonna shoot you in the legs.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, kick time.
Kick time.
Kick.
Oh, what the fuck?
My god.
You should go into pro wrestling.
Oh, god.
Here we go.
I shank him?
Oh, he was dead.
He was dead anyway.
I can't tell when you're dead!
Oh!
Pause, pause, pause!
Thank you for pausing.
Hahahaha.
Alright, nice.
Thank god he paused.
Thank you for pausing.
Hahahaha.
What?
I'm practicing for Sniper Elite.
You know, for the ball shot.
Guys, you won't understand.
It's for the ball shot.
There you go.
Hahahaha.
He really paused.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Woah.
Bro, how come you get arrows, but that one guy gets a fucking rocket launcher?
Jesus Christ, where did you come from?
Yeah, I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
The nesticle shot.
We have to practice somewhere, chat.
We need to find time to practice for it.
This was that time.
Budget cuts.
Bro, that poor guy.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
Just want to make sure there's no loot up here.
Oh, okay.
And there's... nevermind.
What?
Oh my god.
I didn't even count.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
It's okay.
He needs to take time to crawl up.
We're good.
It was too much time to walk up.
Okay, I was going to say, if there's anybody waiting there, because they had to pee.
Pee in the corner there.
I was waiting.
Alright, nice.
Yay.
Imagine if I had to stealth all of that.
Would be a waste of my time.
Hahahaha.
Would have been a huge waste of time.
The pee corner, exactly.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
What?
Alright, we gotta do this apparently.
This is a long area.
I'm going to go to the other side.
Okay, that's a rocket launcher, dude.
I just want to make sure I kill the rocket launcher dude first.
Because like, all these other guys don't matter at that point.
Okay.
These guys don't matter.
I just have to kill the rocket launcher, man.
Alright, get over here.
Oh.
He shot.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, are you wearing anything on your helmet?
No, I can totally shoot that.
That's a gas mask.
Gas mask isn't tanky enough to stop a bullet.
Wait, what the fuck?
You're alive?
Oh shit.
Yeah, he's alive.
Alright, don't worry.
We're fine.
You see those three ammo?
We're going to grab ammo from that one guy.
Supposed to go here.
Okay, there should be loot here.
It's still there.
Still ammo.
Yay!
Like I never waste a handgun ammo.
Never punished.
I love not getting punished.
Okay, nice.
There is a...
Where is it?
I hear it.
The fuck is it?
Huh?
Where are you?
I hear you.
Oh, right here in this corner.
Okay.
I don't even know why I shoot these.
I already missed one.
There's no point in doing these.
Oh my god.
I think you're here somewhere.
Are you?
Oh no, this door is here.
Hello.
Oop.
Go back.
Guys, it's in the village.
I don't think I can go back.
Guys.
Guys, that's how far I've missed it.
It's all the way back in the fucking village.
Guys, it's gone.
It's so over.
You have to move on.
It's gone, God.
Reset the run.
It's the only way.
Where do I go?
Where do I go from?
Do I use this door?
Can I open this door?
No, right?
Yeah.
I hear it.
Okay, this is safe area.
Is that a bug?
Where is that?
Is that the one outside?
I can't tell if it's that the one outside.
Or upstairs.
Maybe they can activate this.
Come on.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
He just walked through that.
No.
What the fuck?
How is that fair?
You can just walk through that?
How did he survive?
Bro.
That's fucked up.
That's so unfair.
Who said he just take the...
He still has...
The worst part is that he still has his legs.
Like I...
Look, look, see?
Okay, someone's going barefoot.
He still has his legs.
Did I miss anything?
No.
Boop.
Oh yeah, I've done the suplex.
Because def...
Like those legs are definitely wrestling material.
Oh wait, the lockers.
I almost forgot about the lockers.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Is there any other lockers back here?
No, it's just those.
Alright.
Yeah, those were all the lockers.
I can't believe it.
That's so not fair.
It was so fucking thick.
Alright.
Gotta save on my typewriter.
Here we go.
Yeah.
No yellow paint.
How was I supposed to know if there's loot if there's no yellow paint on the locker?
Ashley!
Oh shit!
Just wake up!
Are you stupid?
Why don't you just wake up?
Rescue Ashley.
Where are the thing?
Oh
my god.
He doesn't see me.
It's fine.
I'll just kill him before he comes over.
Oh shit!
Oh this is not fine!
Oh my god!
This is not fine!
It's okay!
It's okay.
Yes!
Okay!
It's fine.
See?
Who needs stealth?
Gun.
Gun is my stealth.
I like how after I used my rifle ammo, someone was like save your rifle ammo.
Thank you.
Every fucking time.
Doki!
This is the right time to save your rifle ammo, Doki!
I say as I fucking shot four fucking bullets.
God damn it.
I don't have Ashley for this.
Why can't I just shoot the fucking thing?
Ashley, get up!
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh there's a ladder here.
Oh my gosh.
God damn it.
The yellow paint has to be more yellow.
Why couldn't they make the yellow paint more yellow?
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have my rifle right here.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna put this together just in case.
Alright.
Here we go.
I have my rifle!
Okay.
Let's kill this guy first.
Nice.
Crit.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Boop!
Anything else?
Anybody else here?
I hear you!
Come on.
Get closer.
I can't shoot you in the legs.
I can't shoot you in the kneecaps.
Or the balls.
Nice.
Okay.
Get over here.
Boom!
Shot you in the nuts too.
Just in case.
Now you'll never have kids.
Nice.
Honestly, I'm pretty sure you can't have kids because of the whole larvae parasite thing in you.
I don't think you're able to produce children.
Even if I didn't shoot you in the balls.
Let's see.
This way.
Is there any loot?
Loot!
Money!
Ammo!
I missed ammo?
Oh, I did!
Fuck.
Let me go back.
It's right here.
It's the thing that was glowing.
I missed the glowing thing.
How could I?
It was literally glowing.
You always surprise me, Doki.
I don't like this.
I do not like this kitchen.
Locker.
Okay.
Shotgun ammo.
I sort of need...
I sort of need rifle ammo because I wasted it.
Woo!
Hello?
Anybody in the P-corner?
Lord Crows says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Reminder.
Adoption is always an option.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The fuck?
Why is there like...
I don't like this.
I don't like how there was like a corridor for no reason.
Because that means there is a reason.
Hello?
Oh, hey.
Money.
I don't like that.
Just in case.
Don't even drop loot?
What the fuck?
Bro!
Oh, merchant.
I'm safe.
Why not?
Welcome.
I'm safe.
Oh, is there anything I can sell?
Okay, sell.
Sell.
Okay, do I have it locked?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Oh, I do.
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna make this stuff first before I sell.
Oh, I got another crown.
I didn't even notice.
Alright.
One.
Two.
Three.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Nice.
Another 100k.
Easy.
Oh, I can make another one.
Nice.
Yeah, there was no money.
No way I was gonna find four of a kind.
Like, three of a kind of the same color.
Alright.
Easy 100k.
Boop, boop.
Okay, that is...
Oh, that's a lot of money.
Uh, I might as well just upgrade my knife.
Repair.
And then...
Wait.
Is it worth it?
Nah.
I'm gonna upgrade my magnum.
I already did.
I maxed out.
Okay, technically it's maxed out.
Because I have the upgrade.
I'm gonna do the...
I'm gonna do the fucking...
My magnum.
I feel like that's much more worth it.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
We're gonna have the rifle fight, right?
Okay.
Uh...
Reload speed.
Ammo.
Rate of fire.
Uh...
Let's see.
I guess...
Maybe like more reload, I feel like.
Reload speed.
I'll do...
Rate of fire.
Yeah, I'll do rate of fire.
And then I'll max out.
Actually, I can max it out.
I have enough money to max this out.
Yay!
Alright.
Alright, my rifle is beefed up.
My fucking rifle is so fucking beefed up now.
Let's see.
Don't worry.
This is a tanky rifle.
I can even craft more rifle ammo.
Just in case.
Just in case!
And then I save...
Wait, what?
Chicken!
Wait!
There's a chicken here?
This is not a good place for a chicken.
It's not.
93 saves.
Here we go.
Alright.
Wait, I hear it!
I hear the chicken!
Oh my god!
There she is!
Where were you chicken when I needed you?
I don't like this.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I don't have the key for this.
Still.
I'll have to go this way.
Alright.
Alright, why do I need the rifle?
We're gonna find out soon!
I assume we find out here.
What?
Where do I go?
Freezer?
I'm gonna go to the freezer.
God damn it.
I need cars for everything.
What?
What was that?
Guys, what was that?
What was that, guys?
What was that?
Guys, what are those things over there?
why was he crying?
Are you crying?
I'm gonna use the bathroom of your bag.
Why is it in the dark?
Why?
Oh my god.
Wait.
That's a...
Oh no.
Guys.
Oh thank god.
I accidentally broke my mask.
Why is it in dark?
My
god.
My god.
My god!
I hate this.
Okay.
Your keycard application has been approved by the head of the department.
Please bring your level 1 keycard to dissection and follow the procedure on the next page.
Overwrite card for level 2 clearance using the machine located in freezer.
Overwrite card for level 3 clearance using the machine located in incubation lab.
Please ask each section supervisor for permission to access the machines.
Permission to access the machines.
I didn't even finish reading the lore.
I was so scared.
Oh wait I did.
Oh my god!
What did I open?
I don't even know what I opened.
I'm too scared.
I...
I can't man.
I can't.
I can't!
I...
Where do I go?
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
I hate this so fucking much.
I hate this.
I don't even have the key card!
What do I...
Oh my god bro, I'm stressed out.
I'm so stressed out.
Where do I go?
Do I go here?
Is it here?
Oh my god.
Dissection?
Where is dissection?
Oh my god.
There?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I hate this.
I hate this so fucking much.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh!
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
Where does it need to go?
Oh, there.
Okay.
I'm so confused.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I can figure this out guys.
I did it.
I did it guys.
What the fuck is that?
What kind of experiments are they doing here?
What the fuck was that?
At last, I've created a new life.
I call it regenerator.
This metabolic capacity is incredible.
Unless all the parasites residing within it are destroyed, the tissue can...
Wait!
Can it never die?
They never die?
I can't kill it?
Okay.
Upon examining the body...
With...
A biosensor...
They confirmed that the parasites behave like vital organs for the host, almost as though it has multiple harms.
The new creation mind is essentially immortal.
Surely even Dr. Frankenstein is...
He himself would want to shake my hand in admiration.
I'll be fine if there were lights.
There's no lights.
The new creation of mine is essentially...
These guys made me put down the game for three days in Yoji while I was playing in the dark.
Thank you for the superchat cast!
Thank you!
I'm so full of everything under control.
The subject went wild and escaped from its cryogenic tank.
I was a real fool.
Guys, where's the scope?
Guys...
Where the fuck is the scope?
Where's the scope?
Guys...
Leave me alone!
Oh my god!
Okay!
Okay.
Guys...
Where's the scope?
Where is the scope?
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Where's the power?
Guys...
Guys, where's the power?
Where do I go?
Here?
Do I go here?
Is it this?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Boom.
He's here, right?
Surely he's not going to...
Insufficient power?
What do you mean?
Guys, he won't attack me, right?
Guys?
Surely, right?
If I just...
Nah,
he won't attack me while I'm doing this.
There's no way.
There's no way he would attack me while I'm doing this.
Oh my god.
No way.
There's no way.
Oh god, please.
Where is the power for this?
He's just waiting patiently, thank god.
Please keep waiting.
Oh my god, is that the scope?
That's not even the scope!
I don't need this!
I don't need this.
I need the fucking scope!
Okay.
We're fine.
We are so fucking fine.
Oh god.
What's in here?
Is there only one of him or is there multiple?
Oh...
There's multiple?!
Now there's two?!
Oh fuck!
No!
Okay.
We're fine.
Level 2 keycard.
Do I need to flip the switch?
Guys?
Oh my god.
I forgot the card!
Hey, I'm back.
I got the card!
You guys lied!
It's not done!
It's pro- What the fuck is this bullshit?!
It doesn't matter.
Give me my card.
Oh my god.
Give me the card.
Okay.
Do I need to reset the power?
Do I need to reset- I can't believe it's still processing!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Collecting immortal monsters like Pokemon cards.
Where's the skull?!
Where is it?!
Here!
Is it the treasure?
Where is it?
Go to door 2.
Where- Is this door 2?
Is this door 2?
Is this- Is this the door?
No.
No!
Okay.
I hate this.
This is hell.
This is actual hell.
I found hell.
I found it.
Oh my god.
Real people!
This is fine.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you guys.
Son of a bitch!
Oh my god.
This is fine.
Turn around!
Real people!
Oh, thank God!
What the fuck!
Okay, that was...
That was my bad, I actually didn't see you.
Where the fuck...
Where did he come from?
That guy scared the shit out of me!
Jeez, oh my God.
I looked away!
I looked away for one second.
I looked away, I looked away, I was freaking out guys.
I was freaking out.
Okay, I was freaking out.
I looked away.
Oh my God.
I'm so sad.
Oh no!
There they are!
There's so many of them.
Where do I go?
It's just gonna break out.
Oh my
God.
They're just gonna break out, man.
Oh my God.
There's the scope!
Oh my God, there it is!
There it is!
Holy shit, there it is!
Where do I put it on?
LE5?
I put it on the rifle, right?
The SR?
Okay.
There's the scope.
Very recent power outage.
A test subject awoke from the stasis, broke out of its holding tank, and escaped.
The subject was contained after 20 hours.
We were unable to recover one of the batteries and a tool from inside it.
The cause of this unfortunate incident is the unstable power supply.
The outdated generators cannot keep up with our demanding schedule.
Management must prioritize the needs of the engineer over those of the researchers to prevent something like this ever happening again.
to prevent something like this ever happening again.
Oh my God.
They're just looking at me like that.
I hate this.
How do I trick...
Where?
Where do I get the wrench?
It's inside one of these guys.
It's inside these fuckers.
I can feel it.
It's in there.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Do I shoot it?
I'm gonna shoot it.
What?
Here we go.
There we go.
Alright.
I figured it out.
I'm gonna shoot it.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, there's the wrench.
There's the wrench.
There it is.
Wrench time.
Oh, wrench time.
Key time.
Oh, thank God.
I'm fine.
I'm fine with like...
That's fine.
Alright, nice.
I got his leg.
Oh!
That's not fair.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
There we go.
He has no body now.
He has no body.
He has no body to regenerate!
Okay.
I gotta...
I gotta reload.
There we go.
That hurts me!
Oh!
How was I supposed to know he was that close?
What?
Somebody get up?
No.
Oh!
Okay, reloading.
Reloading.
Oh, reloading!
Wooo!
I do not feel comfortable that they're just there.
I don't feel comfortable at all.
Oh, my God.
this sucks, this sucks, this sucks.
This fucking sucks.
I'm gonna suck so much.
Can't stop laughing.
They still have loot.
I don't want to kill them.
Bye.
I'll do it for the loot.
Okay, that's bullshit.
That is bullshit!
That's a hit!
How?
What the fu-
Oh my god.
Bro, sometimes...
Sometimes I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Like, oh, that's a hit now.
You're shooting through a lot of flesh.
I don't understand.
Why didn't I save more of my ammo?
Why?
I should have saved some ammo.
I should have saved more ammo.
Why was this painted yellow with zero loot?
There's so many questions.
But the other two... I don't care!
Let them live!
Okay.
Ashley, I got the...
I don't care.
I don't care about the gold bar anymore.
Who fucking cares?
I don't care!
I just wanna leave.
I...
I have an
extra one.
Don't worry.
Can I?
You can take the vaccine to eliminate the bugs.
It's like the color of your hair too!
Wait, what?
I thought I got healed.
So what were we doing in the cave then?
What was Louis and I doing in the cave?
Oh, it was only temporary.
I was like, what the fuck was the point?
Oh my god, I hate, I hate the regenerators so fucking much.
I hate them so much.
Ashley!
You're okay, Ashley!
Can you stand?
Where's Louis?
Good question!
He's worried about you.
Yes, let me lie to her.
It's not like she's like in her 20s and can take a lie.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Edgar, thank you for the super chat.
Just a temporal relief.
If the bug matures, you need to take other measures.
Oh yeah, we have to like cut it open.
Ada, come in.
There's a lab.
We need to go.
Okay.
Give me your rifle.
I don't need the shotgun!
Okay.
Thank you, Ada.
Thank you.
Let me read the lore.
We are in prison without warning.
One by one, we are taken to the next room.
I don't know what happens there.
They just took Annabelle.
I'm probably next.
I've got to think.
I need to get my head straight.
All who are infected with the Plaga will be at the mercy of Lord Saddler.
If he commands it, they will work themselves to death with a smile on their face.
Adversely, the hosts become so simple-minded that they're basically useless for any complex task.
However, we succeeded in developing the new superior species of Plaga.
It has no special variability, but the host's cognitive functions are not diminished.
It seems like they plan to be a little more efficient than the other host.
They plan to administer this new species to the girl.
It's clearly important that she maintains her intelligence after infection.
All tests were successful and plans for mass production are moving forward.
The project is a complete success!
But I've been imprisoned.
And preparations to inject me with the superior species are underway in the next room.
Annabelle is not herself anymore.
The smile has been completely white from her face.
Writing is the only way.
The only thing that keeps me sane now.
Not that anyone ever read this.
Wait, does that mean I have the...
Do I have the...
Uh...
Uh, the...
The superior one or the dumb one?
I can't tell, Oblian.
I...
I can't tell.
Let's see...
Good question.
I...
I hate this.
Oh my god, I hate...
I hate you, Ashley.
I hate you so much.
Did you give me a boost?
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Now I have to deal with the regenerators and you!
I should have kept you in there!
I should have locked you back in!
I have the key card!
I should have just locked her back in.
I literally have the key card to lock her back in.
I...
I'm pretty much a master of unlocking.
Alright.
Oh my god, the merchant is here.
If anyone has a moment of spirit, will you please turn these blue medallions into a broken mess on the floor?
I know that won't bring back the old days, but I can't let this stand.
Okay, where the fuck are the medallions?
They're all over here.
Okay.
God, get me off of this island!
Get me out of here!
I don't want to be here anymore.
Oh, there's the barrow.
Alright.
Let's see.
Yeah, I need some new shit.
Anything new?
What do you have for me that's new?
There's nothing new, you liar!
Oh, this is the same thing!
Okay.
Can you repair this?
And I need to repair my fucking knife.
And then... wrench.
Key card.
My crystal ore.
And then that's it.
Why the fuck?
Do I need to...
Can I sell the ore?
Can I get a knife?
Because I feel like...
Is it for selling only?
Yeah.
Okay.
Because it was like...
Because like...
It made me be like you...
It showed me a description for it so I couldn't tell.
Oh!
I can sell the SMG?
Alright.
I'm gonna sell the SMG.
Fuck this.
The LE5.
This one, right?
Is this the SMG?
Yeah, the submachine gun.
Yeah, I'm gonna sell the ammo for this too.
Okay.
Nice.
I'll sell the SMG.
It's already MP5.
Do I have an MP5?
No, I don't.
I was like, I'm pretty sure I don't.
Oh, fucking hell.
Alright, do I have enough to upgrade yet?
Tune up.
No, I need 100,000.
Oh...
Okay, here we go.
Stay close, Ashley.
No, I need you to stay close.
Stay close.
Alright, we're outside!
I like outside!
Outside, good!
Thank you.
Wait, what?
What's that sound?
Look, I needed that money.
Guys.
Wait, I hear something.
But like, where?
There's like...
There's like loot somewhere here.
But where?
How the fuck do I... Where is this loot?
I'm looking up.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
It's right here.
Alright, shooting time!
Shooting time!
Hello?
Oh my god, where the fuck is the enemy?
I hear them.
God, I hear them.
I swear to god, if you're in the P corner...
Okay, there they are.
How?
Okay, just wait here, Ashley.
Just wait here!
That's fine!
We don't need to get closer!
Ashley, you're a detriment!
I'm worried about the...
I'm worried about them fucking showing up because of their P corner.
I'm worried about the P corner.
It's like right here.
What the fuck is this?
Where is it?
There's like a loot thing here somewhere.
I swear to god, I swear to god, if you're here...
I swear to god.
Alright.
Oh my god, Ashley, why?
Why are you still with me?
I missed the fucking medallion!
I can search trash cans?
What?
Oh my god, I can!
Wait, there is...
Wait, there was a...
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh my god, now I can search...
Oh, wait, there's ammo.
I'm sorry, Ashley.
This is important, Ashley.
I am a loot goblin and I need to obtain the ammo.
Oh, yeah, there was one here too, anyway.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Where the fuck is that ammo?
Wait, how did I miss it again?
Okay, thank god I, like, turned around.
Where's the ammo?
Oh, it's here.
It was right in front of me this entire time.
God damn it.
Hello?
There we go.
Crit.
I love me my crits.
Nice.
Oh, what?
What?
Okay.
I could have just done that.
Oh, well.
I might have saved a lot.
I might have saved three bullets if I just walked to the side.
If only I just walked to the side.
Alright, five.
We did it.
What is this?
Oh, we don't need the money.
Do we need the money?
Ashley, are we that poor?
Do we need that money?
Can you find it?
Oh, my god.
Maybe we don't.
I don't want to find this.
I...
Oh, my god.
It's in front of me.
Okay.
We're fine.
This island is actually driving me insane.
I fucking hate this island so much right now.
This island is driving me crazy.
I'm just going to shoot the legs.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Okay.
You know what?
Oh, fuck this, man.
Here we go.
What?
How do you survive a grenade?
Oh!
Here we go.
There's no way.
Twice?
Ashley, I swear, I hope I did not accident...
Oh, nice.
He shot him to his own teammate.
That's good.
Alright, let's go.
I got it.
Alright, stab!
Nice.
Money!
Alright.
Fox.
Oh, fuck man.
I don't know.
I don't know!
On one hand, having Ashley here makes me less scared.
On the other hand, having Ashley here means she is more likely to die by the regenerators.
I don't know, Ashley.
Ashley...
I'm less scared, but also, you are gonna be such a pain.
Such a pain later!
Holy shit.
Alright, here we go.
I could just feel...
I could just feel it.
I could feel myself missing every possible shot...
while you die.
I could feel myself losing every possible shot...
Wait, what?
Oh!
Ashley!
Hang on.
Go do this thing.
Ashley.
Ashley, open that door for me.
Nice.
Oh no, am I by myself here now?
Am I?
Wait, there's a loo here.
Which way?
Which way do I go?
Am I going the right way?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what?
Already?
How?
Ashley, where are you?
I left you friends!
I left you for 30 seconds, Ashley.
I left you for 30 fucking seconds!
Holy fuck, really?
Really?
Fucking really?
Oh my god, I can't believe it, Ashley.
30 fucking seconds and you're dead.
Are you alright?
No, mentally?
No.
Absolutely not.
Absolutely not, Ashley.
I am not okay.
Oh my god, I have to do this again.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Where did they go after?
No problem.
Alright.
Oh, this is...
Where did they go?
Hang in there.
Do I actually kill- okay, I don't kill her.
I was going to say, what if I accidentally kill her there?
The point blank shot got shot.
I was like, that is the risk I'm willing to take.
I was willing to take Ashley.
I was willing to take that risk.
Thank fucking god.
Thank god you lived.
Problem solved.
I knew.
I knew I wouldn't hit her.
Guys, I just knew.
I knew that she would live.
Ashley, why are you... Ashley, stop!
Bro!
Ashley, stop!
You're fucking freaking me out!
She can't... I couldn't see!
Ashley!
Oh my god.
I don't... I can't.
I really can't be bothered.
Here we go.
I can't be bothered.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I don't miss you.
I do not miss you at all.
Don't leave me!
Where did you go?
Where did she go?
What?
How?
Ashley, stop!
Where are you?
Jesus Christ.
Holy fuck.
Holy fucking shit.
I can't.
I can't with this girl.
I actually cannot.
Please.
Please, get in a fucking locker somewhere.
Like, I swear to God.
Just fucking get in the locker somewhere.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Smells pretty bad.
She needs a locker...
Yeah, I can tell.
I can tell!
Okay.
There is loot somewhere here.
Actually, why are you clipping?
Why are you clipping everything?
Please, you are driving me insane right now.
Please.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh, okay, okay.
Sorry, I couldn't understand.
I know I gave the instructions, but like I couldn't understand what they mean.
I couldn't...
I was like, I know you said we go at the same... Oh my... Go in.
Go in.
Live in here.
Just live in here.
It's regenerator time.
I assume this is where I do regenerator shit.
It's time.
That's fine.
As long as I don't have to deal with you.
Oh my god.
Stay there forever.
Just stay there.
Yep, there it is.
Yep.
There it is.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
What?
I'm shooting the head.
I swear.
I swear I'm shooting the head.
Okay, there we go.
Oh.
Jesus.
Cuddly bastard.
Holy fuck.
He's wiggly.
Oh my god.
You're not hurt, are you?
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, you got it.
No, stay there.
Ashley, stay there.
Ashley.
Please.
Stay in the locker.
Ashley, please.
No problem.
Did I fuck up?
Whoops.
One more time.
What button do I press?
I thought...
Oh my god.
What button?
F.
Is it F?
Okay.
I...
One more time.
I can't.
I fucking can't.
What?
Why?
I pressed it.
I swear.
Oh my god.
There's like a delay.
I swear.
There is a delay, guys.
I swear to god.
There's a delay.
Okay.
I swear.
Chat, I didn't do that on purpose.
There's a fucking delay.
I swear.
I didn't do that on purpose.
There's like a three second delay.
No.
Not the power.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Leave it to me.
I'm actually pretty good.
I'm pretty good at this stuff.
Oh.
I swear to god, chat.
I swear to god there was a delay.
Boop.
Oh my god.
I hate this so much.
God, that's just a rat.
It's just a rat.
Just a fucking rat.
Run.
Run where?
Where do I...
Guys, I just saw someone say as soon as I turn the power, just run.
Where do I run?
You can't just say run.
Just run.
Do I run back?
Do I run forward?
Where?
Where is that running?
Do I run?
Just run.
Thank you for the Hakkatsu, but thank you.
Okay.
Run.
Where is the power?
Where is it?
Did I go the wrong way?
Oh, there's stuff here.
There's fish.
And then there's herbs.
Alright, here we go.
Apparently I gotta start running.
Oh my god, I'm running.
I'm running.
Ashley, where are you?
Ashley?
Where did you go, Ashley?
Ashley!
Leon!
What
the fuck?
What the... what was that?
Ashley, what the fuck?
Ashley, fuck!
Ashley, damn it!
Oh my... what?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
Ashley!
How do you do this?
Dude...
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Keep coming.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
I can't believe I saw that.
I can't...
I can't believe I did that.
I can't believe that was real.
I can't believe that was real!
Doki plus fear equals a Looney Tunes episode.
Girls, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I literally just saw her!
I...
Okay, the worst part was that I saw her...
I'm not fucking going back for that loot.
I don't care enough for this.
I saw... she just...
They just stood there behind her until I crossed the fucking bridge.
I can't believe that like...
That was so bullshit.
Oh my god.
That was actually the most fucking ridiculous shit I've ever...
I just can't.
Like, how is that real?
How is that fucking real?
That does not feel real.
I'm not going...
I do not care enough for this.
What the fuck?
Bro, what the...
Bro, what is...
I'm not going...
What?
Okay.
Oh...
What the fuck is he doing?
Okay, here we go.
Let's go.
Let's go, Ashley.
Took care of her a quest, did you?
Yes, I did.
Okay, there we go.
The rats.
Exterminate all the rats in the waste disposal.
So help me keep things clean and take care of those tiny critters.
But which...
Here?
Disposal?
God, I don't want to...
I don't want to go back.
I don't care.
This is going to be...
Oh my god.
I don't want to go back.
Alright.
This...
This makes or breaks if I go back to do the rats.
Will there be anybody else trying to kill me?
Guys, if I go back, are there going to be enemies there?
This will make or break it.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, pro.
Pro.
Ashley like ages me here.
Okay, one...
Okay, I need two.
Okay, one, two.
And then I need a yellow.
Wait, I should know I can do this.
Wait, I can.
Okay, I can do it.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
I need to put that here.
And then I'll put that here.
Okay, that should be it.
Oh!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Sell.
Gold.
Necklace.
Boop.
I think I have...
Wait, I have enough for the upgrade.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
I'll grab the upgrade for the rifle.
Oh!
Alright, save.
Alright, I'm going to use the bathroom before we go walk through the rats.
I'll be right back.
I...
I hate Ashley so much.
I'm feeling...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've never hated a game character.
This much before.
I've never hated a video game character as much as I've hated Ashley.
Oh my god.
It is actually crazy.
I...
I don't care.
I just...
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Hear any?
I hear a rat.
I hear you.
Okay.
Oh!
I knew you were there.
I'm going to save because I don't want to shoot that rat again.
Which one is worse?
OG Ashley or New...
The thing is, I've never gotten this far with OG Ashley.
In OG Ashley, I would rather kill the rat than the rat.
I got to the part where we had to escort... where we played her solo level.
That was as far as we got.
The OG Ashley.
So like, I don't know.
They're both terrible.
They're both absolutely terrible.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I need a no, guys.
I need a no.
Where are the other two rats?
Where the fuck are the other two rats?
Where is the two rats?!
Oh my god.
I don't know where the other rats are!
I got the boxes though.
Oh my god, there's one of them.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Where's the last rat?
Where the fuck... I'm not getting the fish.
Where the fuck is the last rat?
Nothing.
Oh my god, you thought you could hide.
You thought you could hide.
I fucking see you.
Jesus Christ, I see you.
They heard the gunfire and jeez it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Let's go, Ashley.
I'm done.
I'm so done.
So done.
Get over here.
I got the request.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Yay!
Save time.
We're gonna break a hundred guys!
We're gonna break a hundred!
We're almost there!
Boop!
Alright, where do I go?
I don't like this.
I'm getting my shotgun just in case.
What?
Oh my god.
Fall.
Fall!
I'll never trust again.
Guys!
Oh my god.
Why is there so many fucking fire stuff?
What are you doing?
Ashley, what are you doing?
Skizz.
Oh god.
Oh here we go.
We're gonna smash!
Smash!
Wrecking ball!
I'm eating my tangerines.
Just go smash!
I don't care anymore.
You're serious?
Am I controlling anything?
No?
Is this what they teach kids in school these days?
Ashley, you're not certified!
You're back!
Is this what they teach people in school these days?
Is this one private school?
Like ultra private school?
The one with the celebrities and the president's daughters?
Am I supposed to... Oh my god, I'm supposed to fucking protect her.
Oh my fucking god!
Nooooo!
Oh my god.
Of course.
Of course I have to protect her!
Of course I do!
Okay.
Where are the other ones?
Why are you over here?
There they are.
Oh my god.
No, my 70%!
Oh no.
Oh no!
Okay.
It's fine.
It's... It's fine!
It is so fine.
There we go.
I told you.
It's so fine.
We're so okay.
Alright.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
My fucking crane is still full HP.
Why are you just giving me money?
Why is it just money?
Is that it?
Don't hurt me.
Just don't hurt me, Ashley.
Yay!
Ashley, no!
That's what you said last time!
You said that last time, Ashley!
You lied!
Oh, come on!
Come on!
Bro!
Oh, shit!
My shoulder!
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
You are screaming!
I'm screaming!
Ashley!
This!
Oh my god.
Bro, Ashley, I'm trying!
Ashley, I am going through more than you right now.
Oh, jeez.
Oh my god.
I'm going through so much shit right now.
Holy shit, thank you.
Thank you for the ammo.
Thank you so much.
Holy fuck!
You craft.
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up right now.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Get out.
Get the fuck out.
Get out!
Okay, there must be more ammo here.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I dealt with so much today.
I went through so much pain.
Alright.
Alright, get out Ashley.
It's time.
Thank you for the loot.
Thank you so much.
There has been sighting of what appears to be a strange corpse wandering around.
Likely the result of some immortal experiment.
Once someone put it out of its misery and its pathetic existence.
Incubation lab.
Are you kidding me?
Isn't that all the way back here?
Don't worry guys.
I'm definitely gonna come back!
Don't worry.
We're gonna come back.
Alright, let's see.
I think we gotta push this.
Don't worry guys.
I swear we're gonna come back, guys.
See?
I unlocked the shortcut.
That means I'm coming back.
Guys, I unlocked the shortcut.
I'm gonna come back, guys.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll be back.
I... We work well together, guys.
Right?
Fun fact.
You could have sped the process up by throwing grenades at the wall to weaken it for Ashley so it would break later.
That works?
Well, either way.
Snow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're no fun.
All right.
It's okay.
We'll come back at part four of the game.
Play, guys.
Don't worry.
We'll come.
Guys, in part four of Resident Evil 4, we'll come back, chat.
And then... do this.
Then we get out of here.
Oh, thank god.
I fucking hate her so much.
I must stress the use of extreme caution when playing Resident Evil 4.
When handling the amber deposits from underneath the castle, work with the utmost respect and obedience.
It is imperative that you do not disturb the holy body's slumber.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Not the amber right there?
This must be what Luis was talking about.
Yeah, this is the deposit.
The rock.
It's the rock!
See, John Cena's better.
Oh, there's a yellow herb.
I need that.
Let's see.
We just need a red herb.
Okay, I'm just making sure I loot everything.
Anything back here?
What's back here?
Dearest Lord Saddler, I am overjoyed to report wonderful news.
The Plague is a truly magnificent organism.
It has the capacity to live in any vertebrate, be it a human, dog, or even crow.
There are no other parasites like it on Earth.
The superior species is particularly impressive, as it can assimilate with a host without causing any damage to the brain.
No one can oppose the strength of your dominance, my lord.
On the contrary, who will resist one's experience of the other joy that accompanies the absence of free will?
I am living proof how ignorant I once was.
In a few days, I will have finished administrating the Plague to all the high-ranking researchers, and then they too shall know.
And when your plan is complete, the whole world shall know!
Oh, it's Annabelle!
The girl that stops smiling!
She's the one that stops smiling.
Alright, this is it.
Oh, yeah, that's a lot of parasites.
There they are.
That's what's inside you, Ashley.
I wonder if that's Annabelle, the one to the left.
Such a profound blessing for all.
Oh, Splatter.
Welcome.
Oh my god!
He's like...
I am Osman Sadler, the speaker for our lord.
Tell someone who gives a shit.
Oh!
Foolish lambs.
Why do you deny grief?
Oh!
Oh my god, he heals so fast.
Now, abandon your body.
Obey.
Obey the voice of our lord.
No!
Oh!
Don't worry, I'll heal just like him.
Do
not resist.
Ashley, your aim!
What the fuck is going on over there?
No ammo.
Pray forgive these wicked sinners.
My faithful disciples shall deliver to you your...
Penance.
Now, child.
You need not be afraid.
Submit your body and release yourself from fear.
Why not me?
Do I have the dumber one?
Do I have the dumb...
The dumb parasite?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I have the dumb parasite or the smart one.
We got the Leon parasite.
I like
how they just left me.
Like, why don't they just...
They could have...
He could have personally killed me.
Like, why did they leave me?
Why don't you like personally do it?
Wait, is that the...
What is that?
Oh, that's just the normal one.
Turn around.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, was that people?
Oh, what the fuck?
Ow!
Oh shit.
Wait.
How is he gonna come up?
Oh, the ladder.
Nice.
Come on, come up the ladder.
That's fucking right.
My ladder, bitch.
Come on, climb up.
Oh, there we go.
I'm just making sure there's nobody behind me.
Come on, come up the ladder.
That's fucking right.
Wait, how do you headshot this?
Oh no.
Come on, come up the ladder.
That's fucking right.
I forgot.
I just need a stab.
I don't have to worry about it.
I don't have to worry about fucking shooting him.
He's on the ladder.
Alright, nice gunpowder.
Per your request, redevelopment of the island is well underway.
Weapons and other defensive equipment have been set up to guard against any outside intruders.
By the time we are finished, the island will be a giant fortress.
These defenses won't hold up long term, but they should last until we carry out our plan.
And once accomplished, we'll be that much closer to our ultimate goal of world domination.
None will be able to resist our power.
Except for me, because of my thick thighs.
With the power of my thighs, I shall resist you.
Good that I'm getting ammo though.
Holy shit, because by god, I need ammo.
Desperately.
Nice gold bar.
Money!
There's so much loot here, I don't like that.
I do not like the fact that I am getting so much loot.
Doesn't make me feel good.
Is there anybody here?
Is there anybody in the P corner?
No one at the P corner?
Okay.
That's good to know.
That's good to know, no one's going to the bathroom in the caves.
Alright.
Down we go.
This way.
Loot!
I just want to make sure I have everything reloaded.
Oh.
Wait, are these soldiers?
Operation Javier.
Few people have heard the name, even within the highest ranks of the US government.
And little wonder too.
The operation was not made public.
It was conducted in secret and then buried.
The reason being, it was too inhumane.
Now let's start it back in 2002.
When a small unit of US Special Forces was sent to infiltrate an area of South America.
Their mission was to eradicate the drug cartels.
The whole operation took several years to prepare for and only the most elite soldiers were selected to participate.
Wait, why wasn't I selected to participate?
Leon?
Are you not elite enough?
I don't know if the mission was a failure or not.
But I do know the fate of those elite soldiers once it was over.
Apparently, the entire unit was wiped out except for the commanding officer.
Major blank.
And not by the cartels, but by the US.
Oh wait, that's the...
That's the...
That's that guy.
Knife guy.
Oh, I was...
This is me?
I was part of that mission?
It's been 20 years.
I don't remember.
It should have been difficult to extract a single stranded unit.
All it would have taken was a single helicopter.
But for some reason, the military didn't act.
Rumors say that a decision was made.
What's the outcome of a power struggle among the top brass?
Others say it was a directive from the former president himself.
But we may never know the truth since it was all covered up.
But I'm certain of one thing.
The US government let those people die.
Brave young people who dedicated their lives to protect their country.
I want to expo...
Oh my god, he's a whistleblower!
He's...
That guy at WikiLeaks!
I want to expose this crime.
Not because it's my responsibility as a reporter.
Because it is my duty as a fellow American.
Check this out on WikiLeaks soon!
Note 1.
The document concerns Operation Javier.
And was written by an American journalist named...
Blank.
Uh...
Not WikiLeaks.
Oh my god.
This article will never be published.
Blank has already been taken care of.
No!
Thank god!
That's
me!
I'm waiting.
Jesus Christ.
What?
That's why WikiLeaks is gone!
Coincidence?
Phase 1.
Depart from campus because of...
It's because of Resident Evil that we don't have WikiLeaks anymore.
Depart from campus with the target.
Escort the car...
Ashley Grahams.
Oh, this is the abduction of the President's daughter.
Escort the target as usual until the start of Phase 2.
There should be three outside inside the vehicle, including Baker.
Abe's unit will follow behind you in a separate vehicle.
Continue to drive.
Who cares about...
She's already kidnapped!
Do we really need to know this information?
We already...
Whoa!
Whose blood is that?
Mr. WikiLeaks?
Is that your blood?
Look alive.
Where did the crow go?
Shit!
No!
My...
My loot!
My crow loot!
Okay.
Oh no!
Yeah, I shot a crow.
Why the crow?
Because he owes me money!
That's why.
What can I do you for?
Okay, we gotta set up this and then these two.
Ah.
All right.
Do we have enough to...
Okay, we gotta repair and then we gotta repair this.
Uh...
Let's see.
We might as well upgrade our riot...
Oh wait, actually...
We might as well upgrade our shotgun now.
You'll...
There you go.
We'll just have to wait for this anyway.
All right, I'm broke now.
I'm broke.
All right.
Nice.
There's another message at the tent?
I missed out more lore?
No.
Think about the lore, guys.
Won't somebody think about the fucking lore?
This?
Oh, there it is.
Just us?
Oh my god.
It's so nice of him to tell me to get ready for battle.
I know like other soldiers will think about like, you know, the ambush.
But I'm glad that he like prepped me for this.
We're at Save 100!
Our milestone!
Yeah!
Let's celebrate, everybody!
Congratulations!
On 100 years!
100 saves!
Yay!
We did it!
We fucking did it, guys!
Celebrate!
It's like for a birthday!
But better because it's 100 birthdays!
I swear to God, are we gonna knife again?
I repaired my knife this time.
Couldn't have done it without you, Dragoons!
Is that your blood?
Bro, I think you need a blood transfusion.
You think they would want that?
Revenge.
You think I'm doing all this for revenge?
Isn't that what this is all about?
Yeah, what's this about?
You see, in that jungle, I had a revelation.
The most important thing in this world is pure, unadulterated power.
Those Illuminados have given me that.
You know you were always an asshole.
But at least you had some kind of code.
Some honor.
There's no honor in power and money.
Look at you now.
Enough reminiscing.
Move out and draw fire, soldier!
Damn!
Bro, he has a gun now?
Bro, what would be quite being a knife fight?
Why did I just do this?
Did I just shoot him?
Guys, will I?
That's what's wrong.
Woah, he's so fast!
Shake me!
Bro!
Bro, he's special ops!
Oh, his shiny combo means so hard!
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
He's gone!
Bro, he fucking... Bro, he shaked me so fucking hard, bro!
Bro, that shit was scary.
Oh, he's weak?
Of course he is.
Of course he's weak to the knife.
Alright.
Get up here.
Oh, I got a beetle.
Okay, I wasn't... I didn't mean to, but I got a beetle now.
I'm gonna sell that for money.
Oh, wait, where do I go?
He gave me the London treatment.
He sure did.
I guess I'll go this way.
Right?
Is this where I came from?
No, this is where I go.
How do I get lost already?
Guys...
How am I already lost?
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna sell this beetle.
He became satisfied after stabbing you a few times.
Fight over.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I'm going to...
I don't know.
I have a fish.
I might as well just eat the fish.
Like, what am I gonna do with this fish anyway?
Like, this fish is just there.
Wouldn't you sell?
Yeah, I'd rather sell it.
It's 10k.
It's an easy 10k.
Alright.
Right there.
I know the beetle raises my max HP, but look at...
Okay, I know you guys can't see my HP, but like...
Okay, wait.
God, I can't get out of...
I'll just let you know, my HP is practically max.
I like, basically have max HP, guys.
You barely made it out alive.
Wait, how do I...
Don't think.
That was the first thing you taught me.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
He's turned this place into one big trap.
I can't fight him on his terms.
What the fuck?
I'm scared.
What?
What the fucking fucking baby?
Bro!
Oh.
Bro.
How the...
Fuck!
I'm sorry.
How did he know?
I thought I was short enough.
That was my bad.
I actually thought I was short enough.
Ready to die, rookie.
What?
Bro, I hate this man.
Oh my god, bro.
I'm coming!
Why?
Now there's bear traps?
Okay.
How?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, I hate this.
I hate this so fucking much.
Almost got me.
You almost got me!
Okay.
Just so close.
I wonder if I can...
Like, if I shoot here...
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Holy fuck, bro.
I hate...
I hate this guy.
I hate him.
Holy shit.
This guy fucking sucks, man.
I'm no stranger to covert tactics, remember?
Where?
How could I forget?
Shit.
Where?
Okay.
There.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Bro, I hate his love.
Bro, what the fuck is this boss fight, bro?
Oh, shit!
He missed!
Joke's on you!
I swear to god, if there's a trap...
I swear to god, man.
I'm so paranoid now.
I'm actually...
I'm so fucking paranoid.
I swear to god.
Holy shit.
I'm so fucking paranoid over this guy.
I hate him so much.
Alright, nice.
Oh!
The paranoia.
It's kicking in.
It's fucking kicking in.
Where are you?
Where are you?!
Fucking right.
Holy shit.
Okay.
There, yes.
Where is he?
I don't like it!
I don't know where he is!
Where is he?
Okay, this is a mess right now.
This is a fucking mess right now.
Okay, I slowly move up.
I slowly move up.
Did I shoot him so he doesn't show up anymore?
Is that it?
Oh, I did!
I did!
You fucking... Fuck you!
Fuck you!
My fucking... Oh my god.
Okay, do I have more fish?
I don't have any more fish.
It's okay.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm so ready.
Alright.
We're gonna... We're gonna... You know what?
I'm gonna eat this.
I don't need this.
I'm ready.
I am so ready.
What is shooting me?!
Oh god.
Bro, I'm fucking coming over here.
Oh my... Bro!
Bro!
What the fuck?
Oh god.
Evade!
Boom!
Melee!
That's fucking right.
You fucker.
Evade!
That's fucking right.
I am not better.
You are a major.
Oh, that's fucking... That's right!
Yes!
Block!
Break free!
Boom!
Oh shit!
Evade!
No!
Oh no.
Woo!
Okay.
No!
Block!
Oh my god!
Bro!
He's so good!
Okay, block!
Block!
Melee!
Kick!
That's fucking right.
Evade!
Hahaha!
I swear I pressed ctrl.
I swear to god I pressed ctrl.
Oh my god.
Space!
Evade!
Are you serious?!
I swear!
Bro!
I hate him so much.
Why?
Why?!
Oh god.
Bro, fuck this.
Bro, where is he?
No!
Is he like getting rid of his power?
Oh my god!
It's like Naruto!
He took off his shirt and got stronger!
He took his hat off!
He's serious!
He's releasing his limiters!
Space 2?!
Yes!
Look at you!
Look at me!
I'm like... the only thing thick is my thighs!
I need a bigger knife.
I'm loving this episode of Tom and Jerry T.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
What does that mean?
What does...
You're crazy.
You're fucking crazy now.
Oh my god.
Do I hurt him?
So that's your true power?
I can't tell if I hurt him!
Oh my god, you fucker.
Do I have to get out of here?!
Congratulations on your newfound faith!
Oh my god!
Shut up!
Haha!
Haha....
Oh, God...
Where is he?
Getting me out of here...
I swear!
I evaded!
I swear to God!
Dude, fuck this guy!
I can't wait to see you rise!
I pressed control.
There is a delay!
It's not skill diff!
Alright, up I go.
I did!
There is a delayed input!
I swear!
Ping!
It's the ping!
Bro, you have two arms now?
Wow!
Damn right!
See!
There!
Oh god!
It's a...
Oh, fuck!
Bro!
Shoot your fucking feet!
That's fucking right!
Oh god!
Where are you going?
Why?!
Woo!
What?!
Press F!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Oh god!
Please, I have to reload!
Oh fucking hell!
I swear!
When he does this climb!
I'm climbing!
I did it!
Oh my
god!
No!
Mack Mom is for the final boss!
I had the high ground!
Kick him down!
All I had to do was get high ground!
That was always the only way!
And I'll be like, no, I'm better than you.
I'm not a monster.
And then he just turns around and looks cool.
I'm not like you.
And then you turn around and look so cool.
And then he's like, Rookie, you should never...
Oh, he... wait, what?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I did not expect that.
Never mind.
I
would...
The honor!
I thought this was anime.
I did...
I thought we were in anime after he got rid of his limiters.
Damn.
I actually fucking shanked him.
Leo ain't no boy scout.
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
What the fuck was I supposed to know he'd actually do it?
Jesus Christ.
Ryza used so many heals.
Fuck.
I can't believe it.
He actually killed him.
What a madman.
Many... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No.
I'll never be like you.
I'll never be...
President Keeva.
Cue credits.
Chapter end.
Alright.
This is... Oh wait, no.
That's not the worst.
That was not the worst.
Accuracy I've had.
Two more chapters.
We're so close, guys.
We're almost there.
Two more chapters!
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Which is...
This is a knife?
No.
This is a knife.
Alright.
I have this as my knife now.
Make your way to the summit.
This chapter is a pain?
You mean not the one where I just have to fight that fucking Major?
Their defenses are no joke.
That's gotta be their sanctuary.
Oh, there she is.
There's Ashley.
Ashley!
Alright.
Fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
Apparently...
This one is worse.
I'm gonna have to...
The last two chapters is a pain.
Why would you tell me this?
I thought...
No!
How...
Is this knife stronger?
The fighting knife?
Than my combat knife?
Is it actually?
It is?
Okay.
I'm gonna sell this and then I'll sell my...
I'll sell my combat knife.
Jesus Christ.
The price is a hundred and forty seven.
Holy fuck.
That is a strong knife.
Okay.
I invested a lot on this knife.
Alright.
Here we go.
Get that shit up there.
And then...
Coop.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
We're almost there.
Rest in peace knife?
What?
Wait.
Don't.
What?
Wait.
I can do a wheel?
Oh.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
That's...
That's very awkward.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh well.
But look at how cool my knife is.
Now.
Guys.
My knife looks so cool though.
Look at it.
Look at how cool my knife is.
No.
We live with our consequences.
We live.
We live with our choices.
We're not Baldur's gaining this.
With the mistakes we make.
Oh my god.
Oh, I literally, I just...
Oh, what?
What was that?
Oh, is that my reinforcements?
Bro, how did you not kill this one guy?
No, you could...
I was supposed to know!
Who's that?
Oh my god.
Democracy!
Let's go!
Let's go, it's democracy time.
Nice.
I can loot while he does all the work.
I'm in the open area!
I'm here!
Shoot them!
Where is it?
Bro!
I'm doing what you told me to do!
Where the fuck is my...
Oh, now!
A little bit too late, man!
Oh my god.
A little too late!
They're still there!
Oh my god.
Not me!
Bro!
Please.
They're right there.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Right here!
Yeah!
Friendly fire!
Please.
Please, they're still there!
They're literally still there!
Bro, look behind you!
Look behind you!
Oh, thank god, he actually turned around.
Turn around!
Oh my god, thank you.
Thank you.
That's all I wanted.
I just wanted you to turn around.
Holy fuck.
It only took us like 20 tries.
But he did it.
He fucking did it.
Oh, there's boxes here.
Nice.
Boxes.
Money.
Okay, there is a treasure?
Okay, nice.
So much money.
Is it just money?
It is just money.
Guys, maybe I can buy back my gun.
Guys, guys, I think I can buy back my knife.
Guys, I think it's possible.
Okay, nice.
I got a red barrel.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's go.
Nice.
Alright, I'll wait here.
Okay, I'm gonna wait here.
Go do your thing.
You go do your thing.
You go.
Nice.
Yay!
What can I say?
I never miss.
Um...
Yeah, you definitely don't.
You gotta hit me or the enemy.
That's for sure.
He definitely doesn't miss, guys.
Okay, we're gonna get him right now.
Bro, what the fuck?
Who are you shooting at?
Oh, there.
Nice.
I'll just stay here.
It's alright.
Can you shoot that one guy?
Can you shoot him?
He's getting awfully close to me.
He's getting closer.
Helicopter?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
Thank you for the assistance.
Let's see.
Is there anything else I'm missing here?
Alright.
Boop.
Apaco.
Nice.
Loot is always good.
Okay, I can combine this now.
There.
That was the only thing I was missing.
Alright, go do your thing.
I loot.
Go do your thing.
Oh, what is that thing?
Oh!
What
do you mean?
What the fuck?
I have to destroy the anti-aircraft?
Bro, you had one job.
It's locked.
It's locked?
Fuck.
I guess I go this way?
Wait.
Loot.
Don't worry.
He'll be fine.
I just got loot.
How do I get in?
Alright.
Knock knock.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I did not see that.
I don't know.
I'm trying to fucking deal with this guy!
I am trying so hard!
Nobody appreciates me.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Get the arm.
Excuse me.
Okay, maybe I shoot like this.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Where are the others?
Oh, it's fine.
The legs.
Nice.
Alright, are you dead?
Yay!
No, we're not gonna use the nade.
We will use everything we have on the last boss.
Guys, I swear.
Oh my god.
It'll be so worth it.
Guys, we'll use everything on the last boss.
Guys.
We'll just throw everything we have.
All our nades.
All our...
All the flashbangs.
Everything.
Because you gotta believe.
Wait.
What?
Where's the fire from?
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
No.
Where the fuck is the fire guy?
Oh, you're right above me.
So are you.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Okay, there you are.
I did not see you there.
Oh my god.
Where's your arm?
Where the fuck is your arm?
Okay, nice.
Wouldn't it be funny if the boss is a gimmick and you don't need...
Excuse me?
What do you mean the boss is a gimmick?
What does that mean?
I'm sorry.
But what does that mean?
No.
There's no way.
You're fucking with me.
You have to be fucking with me.
That'd be so funny.
But we all know that's a joke.
It'd be so funny.
But it's a joke, right?
Right, guys?
But what?
Yeah, it's all like hypothetical.
It's just a hypothetical, right guys?
Yeah, what if?
What if in this hypothetical situation...
That doesn't exist?
That's not real.
This purely hypothetical situation.
Alright, this way.
What the fuck is this?
How do I...
What?
Wait!
How do I...
Okay, I ran in the circle.
I ran in a circle.
We go back up.
Alright, here we go.
How the fuck do I go get there?
Go, go, Leon!
Leon!
How?
Climb the tower?
Where?
Oh, this?
I climbed this tower?
Oh my god.
I was so confused.
Where the fuck did you come from?
Boom!
Okay, we're fine.
Nice.
And then...
We're gonna get rid of you real fast.
And then he is not gonna shoot that rocket, right?
Nice.
Wait, it didn't even hit him.
Did this man just tank a rocket?
Bro, this is not fair.
How can he...
Oh god, tank the rocket.
Tank the rocket.
Shoot the rocket.
Shoot the rocket!
Yeah!
That's how you game and he's still alive.
Alright, where is this guy?
Why?
I'm just gonna shoot you in the crotch.
Fuck this.
I do not have the patience to headshot you.
There you go.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, he just... Okay, nice.
Crit.
Let's go.
Up we go.
Up we go!
Anybody here?
Oh, machine gun.
Alright, so do you need shotgun?
Not shotgun.
Handgun ammo?
Nice.
Did you see this?
Is that it?
Am I doing anything?
Yeah!
It's so hard to tell if I was actually doing anything.
Nice.
It's fine.
I don't really...
Like, what are you gonna do?
There's so... It's such a long way to get to me.
Like, they have to walk so long.
So far.
I'm just gonna drop down.
Maybe if I just beam this guy down.
Alright, nice.
Drop down.
Nope.
Let me drop down here.
Nice.
Free loot.
Hello?
Oh, nice!
More loot!
Yay!
Yippee!
Holy shit.
Get that door open.
This is like an action game now.
Wow!
What the fuck?
I swear.
This is just Call of Duty.
We're Call of Dutying now.
The only issue is that I'm playing Call of Duty with a handgun.
That's the only issue.
Wooo!
Where did you come from?
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Bro, fuck this.
Bro, why are you running?
Where did they come from?
Where did all of them come from?
Okay, how strong is this?
This knife is actually pretty strong.
Like... Kick!
Nice.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Alright, nice.
Oh god.
Where is he coming from?
Where is it?
Where does it go?
There we go.
Holy fuck!
Give me a sec.
I need a reload!
Who shot me?
What?!
Oh my god!
There we go.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
There we go.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's the parasite.
Fuck this.
I don't care.
There we go.
Shoot you in the leg.
Is he still alive?
How are you still alive?
Where?
How?
Oh god.
Please!
He's spawning!
I don't have enough ammo!
How did you dodge all of that?
Oh my god.
The tankiest fucking sniper out there.
That's actually crazy.
Just leave.
I can't!
They just look at me!
They look so delicious!
You ever just look at people and was like, I can shoot that.
Oh my god.
Now I know why.
Now I know why people hate this level.
Now I know.
Now I fucking know.
This level is actually insane.
This level is so tilty.
You're serious.
Really?
Okay.
Alright, we're just getting rid of you.
Alright, let's see.
No!
Thank you.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Alright.
Door!
I'm trying!
There's so many people.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm bringing the big guns down!
Get closer!
There you go.
He has to, like, super die, right?
Is he super dead yet?
Nice, okay.
They're super dead.
Are you fucking kidding me?!
I literally...
I swear to god.
I literally just got down.
Literally.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, are you super- NO WAY!
No way.
No fucking way.
This is it.
Fuck this.
This is it!
Super nade.
Super nade!
I-
Okay, I messed up super nade.
Guys, I might have messed up with super nade.
Guys, it was made a little oopsie.
Just a little oopsie there.
Look!
I could- It said it was super!
The nade was bigger than the normal nade!
I wasn't using- I was not used to the fucking- I was not, guys.
You don't understand.
I was not used to the fucking weight of the super nade.
I was throwing mini nades this entire time.
You don't understand.
They're different weights.
Holy fuck I made it.
Oh my god.
I'm finally inside.
I'm inside.
Oh my fucking god.
I'm not inside?!
Oh!
I thought it was still a cutscene.
I don't know.
I thought he wanted to do something.
Bro, I'm not getting on that helicopter.
I'm so fucking dead.
Yeah.
There's no way!
Yeah, this man's dead dead.
Goodbye!
Oh, you're training!
Oh no!
He's training!
Mr. Frost, make it down!
Hey Cal, they give us super chat.
They can throw ki strikes again.
The freedom!
No, Mike!
Adam Sandler.
Oh god, now it's bug time.
I'll make sure you're the next to go, Sandler.
Oh, fuck this.
Fuck this.
I can't.
I can't deal with this right now.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, bro.
My HP is so fucked right now.
My HP.
Alright.
We gotta heal.
We're maxed out now.
We're mega maxed.
Oh hey.
Wait.
Nice.
Holy shit.
We gotta grab the medallions.
Alright.
Where are all these medallions?
Is it worth it?
God.
Is it even worth it?
We've already maxed out our HP.
We don't have to worry about that anymore.
Where the fuck is that?
Where is that medallion?
Is the medallion down there?
Okay.
There's like a medallion here somewhere.
Medallion?
Am I looking at it?
Where is it?
Oh my.
Dude.
I don't care enough.
I don't.
Guys.
I am like this close to not giving a fuck about this medallion.
I'm so close.
It's like.
I'm like right there.
Right now.
Guys.
We did not.
We are not close to 100% guys.
There's no fucking way.
Is the medallion here?
Oh wait.
There's treasure.
Treasure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Medallion is somewhere here.
I can feel it.
I feel it.
I feel the medallion.
The bones of our brethren rest in all nations.
The blood of our brethren provide all food.
We die only to be reborn.
We live on through eternity.
We reign absolute.
Alright.
What's this?
Oh my god.
This historical item that I'm gonna sell.
Okay.
It has to be here somewhere.
Where is it?
Where am I looking at?
Where?
Where the fuck is it?
It belongs in the museum.
Oh my god.
There it is.
Got one.
We need two more.
Just two more.
Alright guys.
Use your eyes.
This is your time to shine.
It's time to use your eyes.
Oh there.
I used my eyes.
Last one.
Last one is all the way back there.
Last to be.
There could be no other way.
Guys it's time.
Open your eyes.
Nice.
I knew.
I knew I could trust all of you guys to open your eyes.
Bam.
I did it.
I looked up.
What the?
No.
I fucking knew it.
I was like.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I was like.
Body bag?
No.
There's no way.
There's a random fucking pile of body bags here.
I'm just swinging around.
As if there's nothing at all.
It's like they're wearing nothing at all.
Alright.
I felt it.
Oh.
Guys.
I felt it.
The repairs were complete.
Completed without issue.
Since the facility was previously used for confinement.
The work required to reinforce the airtight ceiling was minimal.
As long as we don't run into any issues with the cooling system test.
We plan to bring in all of the.
remaining specimens from facility 1.
All specimens were successfully transferred.
However, we experienced a slight hiccup during the transfer.
As one of them became violent.
Luckily, the number of casualties was less than anticipated.
Please be extra careful when dealing with them.
I received reports that they are beginning to acquire a tolerance to the low temperature.
Oh my god.
Bro, why?
Do you really need more?
Do you really need to fuck me over even more?
Oh no.
Where is it?
Where is that one?
There you are.
I can see you.
I see you.
Oh.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh no.
It's the Iron Maiden bullshit!
Okay.
I have to do this again.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Do you need more?
Wait, was there...
Oh my god.
This was the way to...
No!
Okay.
Oh, I thought this was not the way to go!
I legitimately thought I went the, like, the detour.
Just wanna be sure.
You know.
Can't trust anybody anymore.
Oh my god.
There's still the snake?
Where did he go?
Where did the snake go?
Guys, I lost the snake.
I lost the snake.
He just disappeared!
Where did he go?
Bro, he's slithered out!
He's just gone!
He's actually just gone!
Like...
There you go.
Nice.
There he was.
He thought he could fuck me over here.
It's not through here.
I guess it's through here then.
Oh my god, I see you.
I see you over there.
I hate that noise!
I think that's the worst part.
Is this noise.
Really?
Okay.
Oops.
There we go.
I think that's what I don't like.
Like...
Like the body bag.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
He bent his head.
That was unfortunate.
I didn't mean to...
There's no way that hits me.
Yeah, there's no way that hits me.
There's no way.
Okay.
I'll make sure.
God!
Bro!
God, I'm so anxious just listening to that!
The...
It just makes me so fucking anxious.
It's so annoying and I'm like just filled with anxiety just listening to the body bags.
Nice.
Oh, fucking hell!
Fuck that room!
The sound of chains!
Fioom fioom fioom fioom!
Oh, my God.
Here you go.
Here's your fucking spinettas.
Grab the staff!
Alright, nice.
And then I'll sell the viper too.
I don't need that.
Do I have a machine gun?
Yeah, I do.
I knew I had some.
I always have like submachine gun ammo for some reason.
I have an egg?
What do I do with it?
I guess I can eat the egg.
You don't need no...
No, I will kill them.
I don't care.
I will kill them no matter what.
Oh, I have enough money.
We'll upgrade this.
And then...
I might as well.
Yeah.
I fully upgrade my shotgun.
Okay.
And then I guess after that...
We can save a little bit.
Oh, my God.
Here we go.
Here we go!
I'm ready!
Reload!
Hello?
I swear to God if there's more body bags...
I swear to fucking God.
I cannot deal with this.
I cannot.
Ashley, please.
Are you- Where?
Oh.
Oh, bug!
Bug!
Okay, bug is fine.
I'm fine.
He's fine.
Bug is fine!
Bug, I don't care as much.
So you're like... okay.
What?!
Man, I was gonna say, that's fucked up.
Okay.
There you go.
Just gonna make sure I get rid of all of you guys first.
And also that mine.
There you go.
I don't know?
What?
What do I not know?
What, guys?
What do you mean?
Chat!
She doesn't know!
God damn it!
Don't tell it.
What do you...
What?!
I don't like this.
I don't like how you're like, she doesn't know.
I don't like this at all.
I don't like what that implies.
Why wouldn't I know?
Why wouldn't I know, chat?
This is terrible.
This is really terrible.
I hate this so much.
Oh no.
Where the fuck is the rocket launcher, man?
Oh, I got the fish at least.
I got fish.
It's not important.
What do you mean?
I feel like it's very important!
Give me a break already.
I feel like it's so important!
Wow!
I'm so sorry.
How?!
Bro, I can't.
Oh my god!
That's where you were!
Oh, my armor does not look so well.
I don't feel fine.
I do not feel fine.
I do not feel fine at all.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna make sure there's no bugs here.
I mean, eventually.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I can't care enough.
Oh, fuck.
Look at all these iron gun ammo.
All will be revealed?
Oh, guys.
But what if I want you to reveal it now?
Is that not a fucking beeper?
I swear to fucking god.
Alright.
Okay, it's time!
Grenade!
Oop!
Ow!
Alright, here we go.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We used our grenades.
We're using our grenades!
That's good!
That's so good!
Next.
Oh my god, please.
I have so much ammo.
Oop!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
We got the head.
We got the...
Okay.
Please give me more.
Nice.
Give me a break already.
It's fine.
We're doing it!
We're surviving!
Stop it!
I told you.
We're survivors.
Now we can go in here.
Holy shit.
There's so many enemies.
I feel like I should have been stealthing this entire time.
Holy fuck.
If this was...
If this was stealth, I would not have to worry about all these fucking people.
I would not have to worry about all these fucking people.
Get out.
Get outta here.
Oh my god.
Get the fuck outta here.
Oh, if only we had Mike!
Where's Mike?
I miss Mike.
I miss him so much.
Mike, what happened?
Mike, you're the one that fucking saved me.
What the fuck?
Nice.
There.
Yeah, my fucking sniper is so tanky.
Holy shit.
I like two-shot this man.
Just...
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh god.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
This is not fine.
This is not fine!
Where did you come from?
Jesus Christ!
Oh god!
Oh, this is...
This is not good!
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
We're okay.
Oh, we're okay.
We lived.
We're okay.
We are alive.
Lure.
Give me all the loot.
Holy shit.
Thank you.
Thank you for all the ammo.
I'm so poor.
Thank god.
Not panicking.
I'm not panicking.
I am very calm.
Turn off.
I'm so fucking calm right now.
Okay.
We gotta go this way.
Down I go.
We're so calm.
We need more fucking shotgun ammo.
We're so fucking calm.
We made it here.
We made it so far.
Wait, what?
Why?
What if I just press this?
What?
Okay.
I'm so calm.
I am so very calm.
Oh my god.
My HP was not very calm.
My HP was like not calm at all.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's go.
Hello?
Oh man.
Why does that look like that?
Why does it look like that?
Oh.
Come on.
Go after Ashley?
What if I don't Adam.
Adam and Eve?
Oh.
Ashley.
Ashley...
Oh, Adam sadly!
I simply wish to share this gift with as many as possible.
A humble wish, don't you think?
You see, we are all connected through the Holy Body.
Bro, what if I just let you keep Ashley?
Can I just leave?
Oh shit!
I'm okay!
This butterfly!
Scratch!
Oh my... Ada!
You could have done this earlier, Ada!
Oh no!
Why am I carrying her?
Ashley, wake up!
Ashley!
Wake up!
Ashley, please!
Please!
Wake up, Ashley!
Ashley, no!
No, Ashley!
Ashley, wake up!
Wake up, Ashley, please!
Please, Ashley!
Please!
Ashley, please!
You're so heavy!
I'm losing it!
Oh no!
No!
What is this?
Still you resist, child.
Run!
Let's go!
Huh?
What do I do?
Go towards the light...
Just go towards the light!
No!
I'm already ...
Go Leah!
Go faster!
God damn it!
Liam, please!
She's not that heavy!
She's like a fucking teenager!
I don't fucking know, just go faster.
Leon, please!
You're tired?
You were never tired when you were fucking running for 20 years!
Oh my god, I have the one key.
Ashley, too heavy.
Oh, holy shit.
Get in there, Ashley.
Get in there.
Get in there, sit in that chair.
Sit in the fucking chair!
Get in there!
Get in the robot, Ashley.
Don't worry, it's not gonna hurt.
We have no morphine to help you not feel pain.
Close your eyes, Ashley.
It won't hurt.
It's only gonna hurt a little.
Just a little bit.
We're gonna shoot the bug?
Ooooh, god!
Bro, that's like so close to her heart!
We did
it, yay!
You're okay.
The end.
And thus Leon could never continue the bloodline.
Oh my god.
That level fucking sucked.
That level was fucking terrible.
That had to be the worst chapter.
That actually was the worst chapter.
Not the bloodline.
Bro, she healed up so fast.
I like how Leon gets to have the procedure while he's unconscious.
He had the privilege of being unconscious for this entire thing.
Oh yeah, how the fuck did Ashley put him on the chair?
Bro, what the fuck?
Fuck Ashley.
We're fucking jacked.
Removing the parasites.
There are two ways to eradicate Las Plagas.
Antigen injection and surgery.
If the parasite is not hatched yet, it can be treated by administrating antigen directly into the body.
Once it is hatched, however, there's not much that can be done besides slow its growth.
With surgery, the plasma can be targeted and killed using a certain wavelength of radiation.
That is...
That was a lot of radiation.
Near the fucking heart!
This is not without its risk.
Oh shit, yeah?
This parasite has attached itself to the host's nervous system.
The host will experience excruciating pain.
And there is no effective anesthesia for this kind of procedure.
Surgical removal carries considerable risk even before the parasite is fully developed.
Once fully grown, however, if it is too late, removing the parasite will kill the host.
But considering what will happen to them...
Death may be a mercy.
Adss!
Thank you, Luis.
He's alive, too, by the way!
There's Luis!!!
Yo!
I bet the guy that opened that umbrella is fucking dead.
Alright, what's this?
To be not be fooled into thinking that..
Las Plagas are merely tools for protecting...
We have empowered Saddler.
It is clear what he intends to do next.
Can you imagine if Saddler had that much control?
Six billion loyal servants at his sole command.
There will be no opposition.
No war.
That's not bad.
Maybe for the first time in human history...
Yeah, see?
In human history, the world will know peace.
But I know how Saddler and the others have oppressed the people of this island for generations.
I know how he treats them.
There's no way to live.
And because of that, I won't let it happen.
Yeah, but like...
Not the most uncomfortable place I've seen before.
But like, if it's like one person, you know, like one...
Like, you wouldn't care when you get control.
These drugs just didn't even boot it up.
Oh god, you know how old this PC is.
What the fuck?
Look how thick that PC is.
Look how thick it is.
This sample, which I've come to call the Yamber, was just sitting in the storeroom collecting dust.
We used to have ample specimens for experimentation in the past.
So it makes sense that this one was overlooked.
In fact, the only reason I brought it back in my lab was because of its peculiar shape.
After a basic analysis, I've changed my mind.
The Yamber possesses a very unique quality.
Although small and in a suspended state, it contains the same organ found in a dominant species, which we've only seen in Saddler himself.
When fully developed, the Yamber may rival or perhaps even surpass Saddler's power.
Oh, this is the one!
This was the one that was in Ashley!
Unfortunately, the Yamber was confiscated by Saddler before I could make any further progress in my research.
He may be onto me.
I need to get my hands on that sample again and escape in order to continue my research elsewhere.
It's the only way to counter Saddler.
Of course, I don't think I can trust this outside group either.
But I've already come this far.
Hopefully, I can sweet-talk my way out of this one too.
I'll have to.
For the world's sake.
Jesus Christ!
Lewis!
Keep all your notes in one area!
Lewis, why are your notes...
...fucking spread to like four PCs?
All of Lewis's notes are scattered everywhere.
Keep it in one PC, Lewis!
Alright, here we go.
I like this.
Get up.
The chink office.
Alright.
No way they're healthier.
I'll be right back.
Do not get kidnapped.
I swear to fucking God.
I swear to God.
Do not get kidnapped while I grab this.
There you go.
Yeah.
Go up.
Yeah, it was 30 seconds last time.
I just don't trust her.
I don't trust her at all.
Oh, I'm so fine.
I'm so okay.
Just a little radiation in my heart.
That's okay.
Doesn't hurt nobody.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Why do I have to bring out my rifle?
Why?
This is where you died.
Do you think she's alright?
Oh, I'm sure she's fine.
She's not the type to roll over that easy.
Yeah, don't worry.
The effects will show up in like 10 to 15 years.
And maybe by then we'll find the cure.
Right, Ashley?
Yeah.
What cure?
I don't know.
What do you guys think is gonna happen when you have all that radiation in your heart, chat?
Do I really need that treasure?
Do I care enough?
Do I really care enough about that fucking treasure, chat?
Fine.
Super heart?
That's how you get super powers.
You don't understand.
Super heart?
That's how you get super powers.
You don't understand.
That's how super powers work.
Wait, which one was it?
Is it?
Okay, it's this.
This is what I'm looking at.
There we go.
Yeah, what the fuck?
I swear I shot that.
Okay.
That superhero's taught us.
Please do not... guys.
I don't think that's what's gonna happen.
Praise be to the holy inside...
Lord Kuros is thinking of his soul.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Super powers.
How else do you explain Chris Redfield's ability to punch boulders?
Women promise paradise on earth.
Man, women, or child.
His love does not discriminate.
Beast, fish, or bird.
Or creature.
All creatures shall be equally blessed.
Praise be to the holy insects.
We are the humble servants of God.
His wisdom will overcome any mountain.
His omnipotence will cross any ocean.
The light of heaven dwells in all things.
Let our bodies be seated.
Praise be to the holy insects.
We are the flock and the shepherd guides us.
Our prayers will be sung all over the world.
And they will be heard by all.
At last, we shall exceed in the stars.
Good time!
Yay!
Oh my god, Adam Sandler.
Big fan.
I love you and Hansel and Gretel.
I actually watched that movie.
I actually watched it.
I watched that twin movie from Adam Sandler.
No way.
Unfortunately, yes.
Unfortunately, yes way.
I have watched a lot of really bad movies.
And I mean a lot of bad movies.
Why?
Look, I watched...
I paid for movie tickets to like movies that I should not have paid for.
Because like back in those days, you would see the trailers on TV and stuff.
And all you're thinking was like, it can't be that bad.
Whoa!
And then like you and your parents would just be like the one of the ten people at the theater watching that movie.
There was this movie with...
God, what was it?
Like this like alien race controlling like a...
like controlling this robot person.
It was so bad.
I...
I'm done.
I don't remember what that movie was called.
But all I remember was we were one out of like ten...
like five people in the theater.
All right.
I think we can upgrade durability, armor.
And then we should be good.
Yeah, the Eddie Murphy one.
All right.
Um, so we actually have a meatsharing party little Pakistan restaurant right now.
in the parking lot of this restaurant.
I think he probably won't be making any potential payments.
He might just have an, uh...
He might just do everything for victory.
Nice.
I'm not very much...
Think it's pretty cool?
If anyone needs something.
I'm gonna do it!
I did it.
Alright, let's see.
I still... oh wait, I do have it.
Alright, might as well.
I might as well max it up.
Okay, I maxed it up.
And then, I might as well get the...
I don't really care about the gun and like this gun.
I might as well upgrade this.
Ammo capacity... I don't have that much ammo.
So I'll just...
I'll just do ammo capacity.
There we go.
I might as well do one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, enough reload speed.
Reload fire?
Might as well.
Alright, that's good.
Alright, let's figure out the inventory.
Situation.
Okay.
Nice.
I might as well use my spinners too.
Alright, what do I need?
Uh, 23.
Uh, gun powder.
Uh...
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh I guess I could get the chip.
Oh my god.
These are... oh my god, I could...
There's some things money can't buy.
I could've...
I could've bought the challenge.
Oh my god.
God fucking damn it.
How do I keep doing this to myself?
Oh...
It's fine!
We don't reload anything!
We live... we live...
We live with our bad decisions!
Chat!
We have to live with our bad decisions in life.
Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Look where?
Look what?
What am I looking at?
What?
Oh, this!
I was like, who?
Where?
Okay...
Is that... I'm like, huh?
Alright, before...
We're gonna look at her.
And then we use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Last bathroom break.
Alright, Ada.
I'm coming for you!
I'm gonna save you, Ada!
Woo!
Let's go!
Oh, thank god.
Yes, stay here!
That makes me feel a lot better.
Please stay there.
Oh, that is very...
Bro!
You're so lucky she did not land on her head.
You're so fucking lucky.
Bro, that's fucking meta.
That gotta hurt.
Bro, she's okay.
She's in heals, but she's okay.
Shoot the head!
Stop shooting the arm!
You're like five feet!
Oh, shit.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Bro!
Oh, fuck!
Those are a lot of eyes!
This is it!
Oh!
This is not it.
Hahaha!
This might not be it, guys.
Let me go!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I got it.
Guys!
This is it!
Wait.
Why is your eyes not open?
This is not...
Wow!
Oh, I go down!
Go down, Leon!
Why am I... Why am I using my pistol?
Oh, God!
Oh, God, run!
Oh, but what if it's...
What if I get lo...
Oh, I can stab your eyes!
Stab his eyes!
Oh!
Run, run, run, run, run!
No!
This is it.
Where's my nades?
Where is my big nade?
Where is he?
Oh, God.
Oh, the babies!
Oh, where is he jumping to?
I'm so lost!
Okay, where... Why am I using my pistol?
I am so confused.
Please throw.
No!
I'm trying to throw everything.
I'm trying to throw everything right now.
Wait!
I have a Magna!
Guys!
Oh, my God.
No!
Let me go!
Bro!
Oh, please!
Oh, God.
This is it.
Oh, no.
Let me out.
Stab!
Oh, thank God!
Phase 2!
This has to be Phase 2!
There's no way.
There's a Phase 2.
There's no fucking way.
I didn't get an achievement.
There's always a Phase 2.
There's always a Phase 2!
How?
What do I do?
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, God.
Invade!
Yes!
Rocket Launcher!
Where is it?
Boom!
Don't miss!
It was possible.
Oh, fuck!
One last shank for the ride.
Goodbye, Adam Sandler.
Your Netflix deals are over!
I didn't miss.
All those eggs trained me for this moment.
Hello, Ada.
Ada.
What the hell are you doing?
Nothing personal, Leon.
God, I hate her voice acting in this one.
Don't worry.
I'll take good care of it.
It's just so dead inside.
Like, I guess she's supposed to be dead inside, but still...
You coming?
She's like mega dead inside.
I think we both know this.
This is where we go our separate ways.
I see.
Oh.
Ada?
Better get a move on.
What?
Ada, what can I...
Ada, why?
Why can't I join you on the helicopter?
Where she go?
Who knows.
I don't understand.
Why would she just...
Oh!
Yeah, we better move, Ashley.
Oh no.
You know, Ada, you could've just like let Ashley and I on the fucking boat.
Like, on the fucking helicopter.
You know?
When it hurt.
Which way?
Okay, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
I'm reloading every fucking thing.
I have.
We gotta go.
Now we can go home.
Yes, we can, Ashley.
Just keep running.
Whoa!
Don't worry.
Jump!
Leon, why the fuck did you refuse?
What?
Oh,
God.
Oh, my God.
Keep running.
They're nothing now their master's gone.
Keep running!
Move!
Ashley, I would love it if you could help out.
Thank you for watching, Ashley.
All right.
Not bad, Ada.
I... I really appreciate that.
I...
I really appreciate that.
You like thrill rides?
You're gonna love this!
Wait, what?
I still have to play?
What do you mean I still have... where's my cutscene?
No cutscene for me, I guess.
Ow!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, this is not good.
This is... what?
The slowest fucking jump to the ramp.
Oh my god, I can't believe no cutscene privileges.
No cutscene privileges for me.
Oh god!
Oh shit!
Oh, we're dead.
Actually, this is it.
Actually, I fucked up.
Please, please tell me this is the end.
Oh god, oh, this is so bad.
Actually, the bonus 1 HP!
We are one hit, guys.
We are... we are one hit!
We are one
HP.
I'm not sure that was insane.
We did it, yeah!
Finally got my cutscene.
I did it.
Bro, nepotism?
Bro.
Ashley, I can't.
Chris won't let me.
I gotta hook up with Claire.
I can't, Ashley.
Bro, I'm scared of Chris, man.
Bro,
answer!
This is a... Bro!
If I don't answer, she's gonna think I killed the president's daughter.
Like...
Bro...
She's gonna be like, oh no.
Oh no.
I'm sorry, Mr. President.
Your daughter's dead.
Leon did not answer.
I can't believe that he's coasting his work.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on clearing Resident Evil 4!
8 out of 10 out of 10 until she opens her mouth.
Can't wait to hear...
Oh, yeah.
Don't worry, guys.
We're totally coming back for part 4.
Don't worry.
Zonderman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I missed a scene in the OG when she...
Oh, wait.
Does she actually do this?
Like, no one kicks her off the jet ski.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chris Redfield, thank you for the super chat.
Yes, the bloodline will continue.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
I'm so happy to beat Resident Evil 4 chat.
I'm so fucking happy.
We did it, everybody.
I'm so tired.
What a journey.
What a fucking journey.
Oh, my God.
Almost seven hours today.
I'm definitely gonna take it easy.
I'm definitely gonna be with you.
What's this?
Oh, that's the cup.
That's the cup.
Is there after credits scene chat?
Are you actually gonna do it?
Of course not.
Guys, there's always been a line for DLC, guys.
I'm already... I'm fucking tired.
I'm tired.
Lord Corosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Considering in Resident Evil 5, Chris Redfield can backhand zombies so hard, their heads detonate due to his biceps being the size of tree trunks.
Yeah, I'm afraid of him too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, DLC gets in the line.
It has to be in the line.
Oh, after credits.
Is that Ada?
Oh, that's the Amber.
Callan, thank you for the 10 gift shits.
Thank you, thank you.
Catch me through.
Mike too.
I've obtained the Amber.
Is that Wesker?
Hey Wesker.
Excellent.
Just one question.
What are you planning to do with this?
I do not pay you to ask questions.
Whoa!
All you need to know is a new dawn is breaking in.
Damn!
You let him talk to you like that, Ada?
Just one may live.
I'm expediting that change.
Wesker.
So, we're talking millions of casualties.
Billions.
How ambitious.
We're changing course now.
He's like, bro, I watched my twins dead.
That's fine.
Oh, that's them.
There's Leon.
And Ashley.
Also, have they eaten at all?
We did it!
Oh my god, we fucking did it.
DDragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry, Chris.
But an OG canon Leon and Ada have gotten jiggy with it.
And at one point between games.
Please, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
GG's, everyone.
GG's.
We fucking did it.
We fucking beat Resident Evil 4.
I'm so happy.
Productions, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know Naomi from JJK was in Resident Evil 4.
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
PilotFood, it's so easy to Ada.
Same.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Is there another actor after credits scene?
Guys?
Is there?
I just need a note.
Is there another actor after credits scene?
I can't trust any games anymore.
Everyone always adds an actor after credits scene to everything.
It's like...
There's always actor after credits scenes for every fucking...
Like actor after... I fucking knew it.
The actor after credits scene.
The Marvel syndrome.
That's us.
We're safe.
Good work.
B?
Excuse me?
I had an 80 plus percent fucking...
14 hour...
I had an 80 percent play... like...
80 percent accuracy rate average.
I can't believe it.
Well, I got sunglasses though.
Nice.
Look!
80 percent!
Cole!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Here, catch.
Thank you, Cole.
I can't... too many saves?
Are you serious?
Is... does that actually...
Does that actually affect your... your...
What?
Look, you can't be too careful with saving.
You can't be too careful!
I grew up with saving all the time!
We're always saving our games.
No matter... no matter where we're... where we are at.
We loot one thing, we save the game.
We take one damage, we save the game.
Oh my god.
We did it.
I'm so happy.
We fucking did it.
Our second game completed.
My game's not closing.
I was like...
I was like, why isn't my game closing?
Hehehehehe.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
I bet you guys are really tired too.
But I had such a fun time!
I had a really fun time beating this game, chat.
I can't believe we did it.
Hahaha.
I apologize to everybody who are fucking dying right now.
Watching a seven... like almost seven hours of this.
But we fucking did it, chat.
We fucking...
Hahaha.
We made it!
That's all that matters!
We fucking made it to the end.
Thank you everybody.
The next game series we're gonna start next is Dead Rising!
We're gonna start Dead Rising next week because it's also a game I've been really wanting to play for a very, very long time.
And I can actually finally play it.
And I'm so excited.
Johnny, thank you!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Yes.
The first one.
I wanna be a journalist.
I wanna...
Hahaha.
Yes, the first one.
I've always wanted to be a journalist.
So I'm gonna play Dead Rising.
Uh, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm a speed runner for this game and I got an A-.
So three hours of completion one time?
What the fuck?
Then how do you get like an A-?
Like, like, I mean like how... like why is it so hard to get like a good grade?
Uh, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was really fun.
Not, not as scary.
Congrats, Doki.
Okay, the regenerator part was so fucked up.
That shit, that one was fucked up.
I did not like that.
I did not...
I, I did not like the regenerators at all.
That shit was so fucked up, man.
That shit was so messed up.
Oh my god.
Oh, I think the worst part was that...
I have to like...
I, I, the body bags.
I hated the body bag area so much.
Because even though I know there was no regenerators, the fucking sound of it was like...
bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling.
Bling, bom, bom, bing.
Bling, bom, bom, bling, bom, bom, bling, bom, bom, bling.
I've been like listening to that song non-stop for like last two days.
Uh, T, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know like... I know like I'm like one month late.
Which is like me with every fucking anime out there.
I'm like way too late for the trend of Bling Bang Bang Born.
But like that song is so fucking addicting.
That is such a sick hook.
Anyway guys, I am gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I had a great time streaming this for you guys.
As always everybody stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!